We used to do commercials,
but now we just add them in later.
So we'll just go live and just start talking or we live.
Yeah.
Jeez.
What was that fucking chaos?
Set some music playing in the background.
Peter Mcgraw,
sorry.
How are you?
A scholar,
author,
comedy expert.
Humor code is two out of three.
Two out of three.
Well I'll just let you folks out there.
Um,
figured out which one of the two,
so you were a,
your book Kuma Code is just a,
it's all about analyzing comedy and the art of comedy,
where comedy comes from,
where humor comes from.
Yes.
No,
it's totally
good.
Pause guys.
Got Time.
And that's it.
You can get it on Amazon.
Audible book available there is to read it.
No nother one.
God Damn it.
There's a,
there's a fucking,
there's some sort of a trend out there where these publishers won't let authors
read their own book.
I think that's a huge disservice to the authors.
Yeah.
Except for Stephen King.
So we,
so you know,
I co wrote this book and the joke was that we were going to read every other
word.
I didn't know her to,
to like make it even.
Right.
Um,
so actually the book,
yeah,
the book's about what makes things funny and it's a,
it's a global expedition.
So I teamed up with a writer,
Joel Warner and the books actually told him his voice.
So it's a co written book,
but it's Joel sort of narrating what it is that we're going through,
like through his eyes.
Right.
And then it allows him to make fun of me for like doing dumb things and stuff
like that.
But you know who,
um,
who,
uh,
narrated the book?
Uh,
his name's Peter Brett Golf Burke off he was on animal house.
Really?
There's a scene with Bill Murray where he like a cost one of the caddies and
he's like holding a pitchfork up next to his throat and he's telling some story
and the guy's like looking really scared and awkward.
Bill Murray,
now bill,
Bill Murray was in the scene with the guy who,
who narrated in the book.
I wish Bill Bill Murray wasn't an animal house.
Oh,
what did I say?
I mean,
Caddyshack.
Okay.
Yeah,
he did animal house right then you guy.
Okay.
Can we use fucking room?
We get that out.
No,
Mr Cosby,
we can't ever get anything from this.
Uh,
we studied too soon.
We definitely,
that's,
I think you golf light.
It's good.
Leave this fucking disaster alone.
Oh my God.
It's terrible.
People are looking at it from a lot of ways,
but the real way to look at it is that how did this happen?
How did this guy trick everybody into thinking he was America's wholesome father
and all the while he was drugging rapist.
It's unbelievable.
It's terrifying.
It's terrifying that a guy like that can make it to like 70 whatever the hell he
was by doing it.
I mean 70 72 minutes since the 60s apparently.
Well yeah,
I don't,
I have,
I can get in trouble very easily.
10 years.
So although lately I've got tenure so I can go down some of these paths.
Right.
But here's the thing that is striking to me is like why does he need to do
something like,
like it's not like the man probably didn't have admirers.
Like there's something,
it's scary.
It's very,
you're very right,
you're very right.
That sort of supports a lot of the arguments that women always want to,
uh,
bring up when they talk about rape,
that rape is not about sex,
it's about violence.
It's about control.
That's right.
And when you have a guy like this,
I mean,
what clear.
First of all,
he is so wealthy.
If he wanted to just older prostitutes and have them wait in the hall,
like by the hundreds,
he could do that.
I mean,
he doesn't have to drug people like white.
And I'm sure a lot of people would enjoy having sex with bill Cosby.
They'd be like,
Oh boy,
I got to have sex and bill cosmetic.
Maybe it's just that he has such disdain for people that he just doesn't,
doesn't mind treating them like objects.
Who the fuck knows?
We're just speculating.
Awful.
I think what it does though,
it highlight,
I mean it's the tits,
it's just a terrible,
terrible thing.
But what it highlights,
I think is that the,
the person on stage and the person in the green room can often be different
people.
And sometimes the person on stage is a lot nicer and friendlier and warmer and
sometimes the person in the green room is a lot,
um,
a lot nicer,
warmer,
you know what I mean?
Like,
so the idea essentially is that,
that um,
when you see someone you see their public persona,
standup comedian and actor and so on,
that's,
that's a character who may or may not be sort of closely related to the person
who they are like,
so I like to take a Gallagher is not at the local neighborhood block party
smashing watermelons and running around.
So you know,
he's like a really nutty conservative.
You ever heard him talk about member?
He's been on radio shows like he's very like fiscally conservative and angry and
you know,
that's,
I mean,
there you go.
Right?
And so,
so you see,
you see this happen,
you know,
people sort of talked about comedians having a dark side.
And some of it is,
is that the act of being a funny person,
you often go down dark,
dark places and talk about the things that are wrong in the world.
But it's hard to know how dark that person is in the same way that,
that it seems like Cosby flipped it.
Right.
He seemed like the Nice Guy.
He would chastise Chris Rock and Richard Pryor for using curse words and yet,
you know,
that's so famous that any Murphy is one of the greatest of all time people
laugh.
Did you get paid?
Tell bill to have a coconut smile and shut the fuck up.
I can just imagine that conversation taking place and she and Eddie Murphy and
Richard Pryor over bill Cosby.
Even that,
it just wouldn't it be great.
Kind of fly on the wall for those two hanging out.
Amazing.
I got to open or not open.
I actually get to go on after Richard Pryor
for the last shows of his life.
Really?
Yeah.
I mean he might've done a couple more after that that I didn't know about.
But as far as I know,
I,
I work with them the last shows of his life at the,
uh,
at the comedy store.
That's crazy.
And how is it that you had to go after him?
Because the comedy store,
um,
was run by Mitzi shore in Mitzi shore had a really a do or die philosophy.
She had like a gladiator philosophy when it came to comedy.
She would take comics and if she thought that any potential whatsoever,
she would shove them against the most damning odds.
Like I used to have to go on after Martin Lawrence when Martin Lawrence was on
Martin and he would do like 45 minutes in the main room and disturb
people have like slept on Martin Lawrence and I don't know how it happened,
but Martin Lawrence for Wa at one point in time he had some issues.
You've got a little crazy and you know,
remember it was like we're in a rubber suit and he got pulled over by the cops
and he had a gun or something.
And remember that when you guys more often
give me the real insight on stand up comedy.
But uh,
yeah,
he had,
he had some sort of a breakdown.
Um,
but uh,
before that,
I mean I think a lot of that is probably stress related just from being such a
fucking mega star.
But before that,
he would come to the comedy store and fuck and a straw.
And I used to go on after I eat just giant platters of shit.
I would bomb every time I'd go on after dice clay.
I'd go on after anybody who was like,
if there was a big name,
Mitzi would shoved me on right after she,
she likes you.
I mean she believes in you.
Yeah.
It's like sink or swim bitch does it,
you know,
you can't get those eight o'clock cushy spots after August Hamilton when
everybody's nice and warmed up and friendly and no one's drunk yet.
No,
no.
You're going to go on at 10 45 after,
you know,
a guy like Damon Waynes does 45 minutes and destroys.
Um,
anyway,
so I started weight training.
Yeah.
I got scared.
Fight off the audience.
Um,
I,
so I uh,
would go on after prior and they would bring prior to the stage and it would
take literally,
I'm not exaggerating at least four or five minutes to get him to the stage.
Okay.
Cause the RS or small room,
the original room.
But you have to start in the back and two guys would have to carry them so
they'd have to walk with them.
They had a clear of the path and make the path towards the stage larger so that
you can get them through.
And then they would slowly walk him down the aisle.
They'd literally like picking him up,
stepping,
picking him up,
stepping in and his body was just gone.
He was severely deteriorated.
Then they would put them on this chair and he would drink and he was on
medication.
He was still drinking and they would crank the mica.
Sure.
Like
Papi,
cause he,
he couldn't talk so you had to make it really loud so he could talk and,
and then you know,
people get really bummed out and then I'd have to go on after him.
It depended on how much time he would do.
Sometimes he'd do like a half an hour,
sometimes he'd only do like 20 minutes.
But you know,
you're watching arguably the most influential,
greatest standup comedian of all time.
And this is his,
his last days.
And it was just,
it was hard back.
And watch some of his stuff.
It's,
I,
I was really interested to go back and watch classic.
Yeah.
Stand up.
And the thing about Richard stuff is as opposed to Eddie Murphy stuff,
it holds up really strongly.
Yeah.
In a way that it topically even it,
it would he wonder like what would happen with a guy like that today and the
machinery like where would he have gone in terms of television film?
It's a good question along because he's just so,
I mean he's so funny.
Yeah.
And he's so likable in ways that you know,
he was the best,
I think Kinison was probably the best for like a year but overall priors the
best cause like I think Lenny Bruce is the most important bill bill already.
They just took himself out of consideration.
Who did bill God,
he's out.
So it's funny,
a just not even like a few months ago bill burr and I were planning on taking a
trip to Vegas just to see bill Cosby.
We were,
we were plotting it out and we're like,
let's just take a weekend off because everybody always raved about how good he
is.
Like I've heard a bunch of comics,
like Chris Rock was raving about it.
Chris Rock was saying that he felt like an amateur after he saw bill Cosby and I
watched his special and I was like,
man,
I don't know like this seems like fucking like some really like conversational
middle of the road stuff,
not,
you know by any means offensive.
It wasn't that good to me.
I know he was brilliant back in the day.
Like you go listen to like that Noah's Ark bit and all that stuff from like way
back when.
But the stuff that I was watching and he was doing recently,
I was like,
all right,
we should just go just just because a historical thing and then all this shit
comes out.
Anyway.
Hannibal thinks about all this.
He's probably just fucking hide flaws.
Handball,
I'd fucking high because that guy might get you killed.
I mean think about it like how much money does bill Cosby have and how much time
does he have left on this planet?
And he's got to connect the fact that this one like really respected standup
comic started calling him a racist or a rapist rather,
and I said racist,
a rapist on stage and then it hit,
I forget where it,
I mean like the next day it showed up online.
Yeah,
but it's taken a little while to pick up.
Well everybody knew about it before then.
This is what,
it's really weird.
It's like almost like a volcano that gave you a bunch of warning or options and
then spewed because there was stories from way back in the early two thousands
of you know,
improprieties as well.
And it was mildly in the news when Hannibal's started talking about it.
That's how he started talking about it in his act.
He had done it for a few weeks,
a couple of times here and there.
But yeah,
he just said like,
go Google it.
It's all over the news.
Just no one's paying attention until this happened.
So maybe you could explain this to me as someone who I'd visit La,
I sort of pay attention a little bit to going on here.
Obviously
have gotten connected into the comedy scene.
How is it that there are these,
uh,
what is it like dark stories that everybody sort of knows and in Hollywood,
but no one ever talks about outside of that?
I don't think there's that many anymore.
Okay.
You know,
I think things like this,
like this is as dark as it gets.
And this is,
this is an evil crime of the epic proportion.
I mean,
and one that there's going to be no justice,
right?
That's the thing that makes it very,
how can that be?
I mean,
even if you put them in jail,
how much time does he have left in his life?
And he lived this like fantastic existence for 70 plus years.
I'm sure right now,
none of that matters to him.
I'm sure right now he is in hell.
And that's one of the weird things about the,
the concept of Karma.
You know,
like when you,
you,
you do evil shit to people.
And even if you've got away with it for a long time,
it's probably still creeping away in his insides constantly.
And then when it finally does overtake him like right now and he's just swarmed
by allegations,
it must just feel like hell.
It's got to feel like hell.
Speaking of hell,
if someone had told me when we set this up that we were going to be spend the
first half of this podcast talking about bill Cosby and the rape allegations,
I never would have believed it.
I never would've believed that either.
I never would have been somebody on Twitter wrote that like for the first time
in 40 years Charles Manson is,
has having a better week cause me cause Mansik got married.
Yeah it's fucked man.
The the dark side thing.
Yeah.
I want to hear what you have to smile might take on that.
Um,
a lot of comedy comes from people being scared or bullied or making light of
situations and that's where they sort of develop their sense of humor,
including mine.
Mine was like sort of a deal.
It came about through a different angle.
But as all sort of the same thing.
And I think a lot of comics were ignored and we're not loved and they developed
this exorbitant need for attention.
It's so powerful.
It makes them want to stand on a stage.
Like they're trying to get it all back.
It's almost like they're trying to seek balance from what they didn't get in
their childhood.
That's almost everyone I know.
Yeah.
Okay.
So I,
so I buy that.
Like that makes a lot of intuitive sense.
The challenge with that is that that's the same story that people put forth for
other artists,
for musicians and for painters and like that they,
that their art arose from this dark sort of place.
And it's a way to kind of try to fix things,
try to cope or you know,
kind of be,
um,
to feel positive again.
Um,
and then the other thing is though,
there's lots of people who've been bullied and scared and had terrible
childhoods who don't become funny.
Right?
So,
so,
I mean,
I think that there is something to this notion.
Um,
but I wonder how,
how specific it is to comedy and what is it the differentiate someone like you
versus someone who never became funny,
like,
you know,
so,
so what,
where's that mechanism?
Cause I,
I that I don't have a good answer too.
I have an answer to why people seem messed up who,
who do comedy because most people don't get on stage and tell the world about
their problems.
Um,
but there's plenty of people in the audience who were abused as kids and they're
alcoholics and are divorced and all these kinds of things.
So it,
so it's an,
it's a really interesting puzzle and it's certainly one that,
that there's a lot of evidence for because you really notice when a seemingly
happy comic commit suicide like Robin Williams or you know,
someone Odis,
et Cetera.
And so,
so what is it though that you can point to
that,
that made you go down the path of comedy versus some other path?
I can,
I can comment on this in a unique way because there was a lot of other points of
focus that I use to try to distract myself from [inaudible],
from my unhappy childhood that weren't funny at all.
Okay.
I was an artist and I was really heavily in Dilek drawing comic books
and then I became a martial artist and I started fighting from the time I was
like 15 till I was like 21 that's,
that was my entire focus in my life.
So during that time I wasn't funny at all.
And the only people that I would make laugh was like guys in the locker room and
it came out of a,
a fear like we would spar and sparring.
Scary cause you know,
you're practicing fighting and a lot of times you're like,
the way to get good is you got to hit each other really hard.
You've got to do it.
Like it's a real fight.
You kind of pull back a little bit sometimes,
but it's just scary as shit.
And oftentimes you're sparring with people you don't know.
And that turns into like an actual fight.
So every sparring session we would do,
especially on Saturdays where this big thing called team training that we do on
Saturday morning.
And I would make everybody laugh.
I would be the guy who'd be like cracking jokes or doing impressions of people,
but I was only doing it because I was scared and I was doing it for them cause I
wanted them to pay attention to me.
I think that all the other energy that I put forth into art and into,
um,
into,
martial arts was just trying to calm down whatever fucking ridiculous storm was
inside my head because I didn't get enough attention or my life was fucked up
or,
you know,
fill in the blank for whatever it is.
And I think the path of comedy is just a unique path in and of itself because
there's so much criticism and analysis and self analysis and judgment by the
audience and then this pressure to produce comedy.
There's so much going on on top of the initial motivation that got you into it.
But I think that path can go to guitar playing that path can go to,
it's just trying to find something that makes you feel special.
And if you,
I mean there's a bunch of people that have that issue in their head and they
never figured it out and they've bounced around in normal jobs and never can
keep it together and become drug addicts or alcoholics or you know,
fill in the blank.
But I think it all comes a very similar place
and it's really weird that our society that,
that human beings rather are like that.
But if you don't get enough attention at certain ports in your developmental
process,
he developed this exorbitant need for an unbalanced need for attention.
And you either learn how to deal with that and learn how to channel it or you
don't.
But if you do learn how to channel it,
it's like a massive advantage.
It's like being a crazy attention to whore if you can keep a handle on it.
It's like what an like an engine for motivation.
You have,
I think in some ways you,
you really need that to make it in this business,
right?
It's such,
you know,
standup comedy.
So I,
I gave it a shot.
I actually,
that's what started the humor code project was this journalist,
uh,
said to me,
you know,
I want you to come to this open mic night and critique the comedians.
Tell me why they're funny or not using your theory.
And in a moment of Hubris,
I said,
well,
I want to get on stage and tell some jokes.
And you can imagine how that went.
It did not go well.
How long did you prepare a,
this is embarrassing.
It's embarrassing to say now because I know about the business.
I prepared like 24 hours.
That's better than not at all.
Yeah.
It's,
I mean,
I understand.
I get it now,
but you know,
when you're,
when you're outside the business,
you don't really understand what goes,
what goes into it.
And then at the end of the book,
at the end of our travels,
I got on stage again this time at just for laughs and a real comedy club in
Montreal,
in Montreal.
Oh,
okay.
At the comedy nest.
Oh,
okay.
And then to sort of prove,
but I've learned something along the way.
Get laughs.
I did.
Oh,
that's awesome.
I did.
Yeah,
it was good fun.
it was fun.
But uh,
but uh,
where was it going?
Oh,
the idea is that fit to want the attention to want to succeed so badly.
It is necessary.
It's not sufficient,
but it's necessary because you face challenges,
you face failure,
the risk of failure all the time,
failure regularly.
And then you just have to do it constantly to be able to get those sort of
shining moments that I think helped propel you even further along.
Well,
it's also,
um,
in order to get good,
you have to accept that failure and you have to absorb the pain.
It's a very weird thing,
but I find that the more satisfied I am with what I do,
the shitty or my product is.
And the more I'm disgusted by everything I do,
the better everything is this.
I like,
I could have a murderous set where I'm killing for an hour and I'll fuck one set
up of one thing.
And that's all I think about for like days.
So like there's like this intense never satisfied sort of narrative that keeps
going on when I'm really working on something and I really get into it.
I'm never satisfied.
Well there's a,
so there's this,
if I could be a professor for a moment,
so there's what's called,
we called the negativity bias or negativity dominance and it's essentially the
idea that the negative things in the world hold much more sway over our
decisions,
our emotions,
our reasoning than positive things.
And it's,
it's part of the reason that that one little element can out shine outweigh and
it,
you know,
59 minutes of other good stuff.
And,
um,
I mean,
that makes,
it makes sense from sort of an evolutionary standpoint.
But then when you think about the stakes associated with wanting to become a
standup comic,
it,
it actually becomes really rational to pay attention to the,
to those failures because you have to eliminate them or fix them if you want to
get that hour special,
that just shines.
Yeah.
You also,
you don't do yourself any good by being happy with your work.
It's fucked up,
but it's true.
It's like you,
you,
I mean I'm happy with the results.
Like I know like objectively that was really good,
but I there I could go look at my last special,
which I think the ones coming out,
it's coming out tonight.
Oh,
why a on comedy central at midnight is a time.
It's the first night,
but I think it's my best one,
but I always think that,
but this one I really do like objectively think it's my best one.
I put in way more work into it then my last one,
but I could go back and watch a bit like five times and get crazy and go,
what the fuck did I do it like that for like if I just did this or like you
can't,
they can never find like a peaceful moment.
And it's because the stakes are so high first of all.
And the,
the impact of it,
like when it's,
when you,
when you get it good,
when you really get it and nail it and,
and the audience is dying laughing and then people go,
that's my all time favorite bit like that.
That is so fun.
Like that is such an important thing to be able to accomplish.
It's so,
and there's only one way to do it.
You got a fucking crawl through glass if you don't crawl to glass,
if you don't really look at it for what it is,
it'll never get to that point.
And the only way to,
to look at it like that is you gotta be like super hyper critical.
And if you're hypercritical,
you're going to fucking hate everything.
You're going to everything until you know,
I,
um,
so I did my postdoc with Danny economen,
so he won the Nobel prize in economics for psychological insights into decision
making.
And I've worked with him before.
I did the post doc when I was a graduate student.
He was in his late sixties at the time.
I was in my late twenties and I helped him edit a couple of chapters.
And that guy,
what you just described is him,
he,
he would write a paragraph and I'd be like,
oh,
it was great.
And he goes,
no,
no.
And then he would rewrite it in front of me and we'd taken my 45 minutes and
then I like,
oh yeah,
that's better.
I go,
no.
And then he would just write it over again and we would,
so we work on a paragraph for like three hours that I already thought was good
and at the end of it it was great
and then we'd just move onto the next paragraph.
And it,
it's just like,
I think that,
that,
that idea of being so obsessed,
obsessed with getting it perfect is what you need to get something near perfect.
Yes.
The only way you really achieve what we want to call greatness.
Ernest Hemingway has this great quote that my friend Ari Shaffir has taped on
the front of his laptop,
the first draft on everything.
It's shit that's shitty.
First round.
He just,
he puts it right on his laptop,
like right where the,
uh,
the thing above the keyboard.
So he looks at that every time he writes and it's just,
that's what you gotta do.
You gotta write and then you gotta rewrite and then you got to analyze and you
got to listen.
Like Brian and I were actually just talking about this last night.
It's fucking hard to listen to yourself.
He's like,
I hate my voice.
I fucking hate what I sound like.
I figured it out.
If you put it on double speed,
it sounds a little different.
Like it doesn't sound like that voice.
You tried to hack it,
trying to hack,
listen as long faster.
And you know what you're talking about already said if you listen to double
speed,
it's the way to go.
Because that's the problem I have is my voice is so gross.
You know,
you should listen to your voice and fix that shit.
That's what you're supposed to do.
You're supposed to do something that doesn't seem gross to you,
but you're like,
oh fuck you.
Reality Changing.
Your voices messed up though.
No,
you just have to or you don't have to change your voice.
You just have to calm down.
Just calm down.
You silly goose.
So,
uh,
what's the name of your special?
Uh,
rocky mountain high.
Okay.
So Denver Song John Denver had to I to use it.
Plus I,
I did it in Denver.
Uh,
it was right after the comedy works in Denver.
I decided,
yeah,
it's the best.
I decided to do it at a comedy club,
first of all,
because I wanted to,
because I think that I've been doing in these theaters.
So I had a lot,
a lot of decision making after my last special,
the live of the Tabernacle one I did,
wasn't that happy with it.
I was happy with some bits,
but otherwise I was like,
man,
if I had like more time to work on that,
I could've made that whole thing better.
And then I thought about it,
I'm like,
you know,
another thing is I don't think that that's the right environment for doing a
special,
like on a giant stage.
I'm like when you watch someone in a comedy club and you're in your living room,
like you're right there,
you know,
like you feel like panic wide shot.
Exactly.
Yeah.
So I didn't want any of that very little shots to the audience.
I just wanted to just focus on the thing like you or someone in the audience,
you're just watching in the audience.
And I'm a Denver is just,
you know,
right now it's just changing so radically because of the marijuana being legal.
It's just bizarre.
The culture is expanding and it's really strange way that every buddy idealized.
Like this would be the ideal scenario.
You get $100 million a year in taxes and you know the,
the violent crime drops,
drunk driving drops,
murder rate drops.
But that's actually what's happening.
And it,
you know,
um,
sort of like tons of young people moving there.
The tech scene is booming.
Yeah.
It's,
the city's doing very well blowing up and it's going to continue.
It's an amazing,
amazing place.
Colorado's my favorite spot.
I'm stuck here for a little bit.
I'll fucking get back to those mountains.
You just can't beat that view.
That view is insane.
Yeah.
It's a nice place to live.
God Damn.
I don't want to bring everybody to move into your neighborhood.
Well,
I,
I own,
so that's okay.
Help.
Uh,
you know what it is.
So here's the thing that I like about Colorado was the thing that I also don't
like about Colorado is that,
so I live in boulder,
so,
you know,
I'm 30 miles north of,
of Denver is it,
it's just such an easy place to live.
It's just things functioned very easily and everybody is very nice and they're
fit and you know,
things run well and so on.
So you could be productive.
You can be creative there,
you can get stuff done,
then you can be healthy doing it.
But I like coming to La.
Um,
although La is a lot harder as you as you know,
but it's also,
there's like this is also a hub in ways that a place like boulder or Denver
can't be,
you know,
there's just,
it's just so the scale is so much bigger and the,
the people that you meet are just doing big things
like Adderall.
Yeah.
This is a crazy place cause it's supposed to have this many people.
You know what I went to recently?
What really cemented it?
I went to Mexico City.
Oh yeah.
I was in Mexico City for the UFC.
First of all,
it's like a robot farting in your face 24 hours a day.
That's what Mexico City smells like.
Like it is so polluted.
I have,
I put a photo on my Instagram and people were like,
Holy Shit.
Like when you're flying into Mexico City,
you like,
Whoa,
that's dark.
And it's perpetual gridlock.
So you know how like sometimes in La you get to a greenlight in some assholes,
they drove into the intersection and the light changes and they're stuck there
and everybody honks and you know,
everybody tries to be more courteous and they go around the guy and he goes,
and then you behind them,
she makes sure that you don't do that.
You give yourself a little gap room,
you know,
so like this is why it's about to change.
Let me hover back here so I don't fucking bother them.
They don't ever do that in Mexico.
That shit doesn't happen.
So when you're driving at five o'clock there's just jammed up this way and
jammed up that way.
There's red,
green,
it doesn't matter.
The light turns green,
you move forward,
little light turns red where they go on,
they're fucking,
they're right there and you're parked in the middle of the intersection.
It's perpetual gridlock with the nicest people.
That's the other thing that was trained.
Honking cars are honking and makes very little,
very little.
It's very friendly,
very nice people like there's way more people than the Ryan la,
but everybody's really chill.
Like they're super friendly,
like Mexican people in Mexico City or some of the nicest people I've ever met
and any foreign city.
Like when I first went to,
it's like consistently nice.
That's great.
Yeah.
You know,
and they didn't know me.
There's just,
they were just normal,
nice folks.
But that,
that monster of traffic and gridlock and people is what we're going to expect in
La.
It's is going to happen if it,
if it doesn't happen in 20 it'll happen in 50 or a hundred years,
whatever it is.
Like that's inevitable
and that's fucking chaos.
Unbelievable chaos.
There's too many people.
I read this thing that La county has more people than all,
like I think 13th it's like if it was a state,
it'd be like the 13th largest state or something like that.
Just La County.
Yeah,
that makes sense.
Thing like that.
That's,
that's really obscene.
It's enormous.
It's an enormous,
enormous amount of people and it's very strange.
It's like,
um,
he got a wonder like what does everybody here for?
Like how many,
how many of these people are here because of show business?
Like what is the actual number?
Because there's a lot of people that go,
well you know,
I'm gonna give it a shot,
go California.
And they have like sort of this like very non committed idea of trying to make
it in show business,
hoping they make some connections and along the way they quit.
Like I've been a lot of people like that.
Right?
There's a lot of people like that do you mean?
Yeah,
I think a lot of them are in,
in,
in the show business,
but there's so many different kinds of like,
I think porn exteriors.
I mean there's so many just people.
Is it very quick?
People in Porn,
extras.
That is just the worst example ever born extras.
Hey,
we're looking for porn extras.
Yoshi keeps on contacting me to be a coronet actually bro.
Yo,
she's fucking crazy.
Why are you pretending like Yoshi is normal?
Like,
oh,
it's normal.
He,
I an example for you.
He's like,
he says he thinks they want to do it.
it's $100 and you get to watch porn and you just have to stand in the background
whether people will fucking do it.
I'm glad I'll release them to this.
The double speed.
This is,
yeah,
this is the time to fast forward porn extras wouldn't fucking terrible example.
There were,
so there's a,
there's a bit in there though,
right?
Probably porn extra bit.
It's probably a bit in there.
Yeah.
My friend was a porn extra,
he was be had to be behind a blow job scene.
We're,
Spiderman was hanging upside down and she was giving him a blowjob upside down
and he just was like inches away.
Having to just sit there and go wider man against the wall or a web to school.
Yeah.
Okay.
That doesn't,
that doesn't get central casting.
Doesn't send people out for that stuff.
No.
They probably have Zillow,
craigslist things,
probably all nonunion,
you know,
the whole deal.
But,
um,
anyway,
back to motivations and standup comedy in this.
Now,
did you,
how did you,
um,
like come to conclusions or extract data when it comes to like know,
so I have a,
I have a lab at the University of Colorado called the humor research lab,
the actual lab.
But you wear coats.
We don't,
people always want us to,
you know,
the media.
It was like,
where do you have any lab coats?
Any rubber chickens.
Like whenever rappers referred to like their little,
where they write as the lab,
like kid Cuddy,
I want them to wear a lab coat.
You were in the lab,
fucking take this shit to the next level.
We thought about it for like,
when we bring in,
um,
participants for subjects,
we thought about wearing lab coats just to make it like for the,
for the subjects to take it more seriously because it's like lab coats say
science,
we should get some beakers,
you know,
things like that.
But
now we don't do any of that stuff.
Okay.
But,
uh,
but so the,
by the way,
the,
the acronym is hurdle.
So we,
we refer to the human research lab has hurled.
Oh,
okay.
Her role with laughter.
Yes.
And uh,
we,
uh,
so,
so we,
so what we did was sometimes we would run experiments out in the field,
sometimes we'd run experiments back in the laboratory so we'd have an idea,
we'd go out and investigate it and then oftentimes with supplement that,
that work in the laboratory or elsewhere.
So.
So you,
you mentioned comedy works as being such a great room.
Uh,
one of the things that we,
that we do in the humor code is investigate what makes a great comedy room.
And we actually tried to construct a,
a comedy club at this art museum that was doing a special event.
So we showed comedy clips and we,
we changed aspects of the,
of the room to see if it would actually have an effect in the way that you would
expect based on your experience as a comedian.
And sometimes,
you know,
the,
the studies work,
sometimes they don't work,
but it served as a nice,
um,
scene by which to talk about.
Like,
we don't,
why is it the comedians are especially funny in a comedy club?
Like why,
what helps make a joke land?
What did you come?
What were the conclusions?
So,
um,
so one of the things that people always talk about is like having the low
ceiling and how beneficial a low ceiling is.
And so like,
okay,
well why is that the case,
you know,
so that they'll say is that,
that the laughter will kind of bounce back down onto the audience.
And if you think about it,
what,
what laughter really is,
is a communication tool,
right?
It's a primitive communication tool.
So babies law,
you don't need language to laugh,
right?
Babies laugh monkeys,
chimps,
bonobos receiving even evidence that rats engaged in something akin to laughter.
And,
uh,
and what it does is it,
it communicates that this situation,
and this is getting into the theory that we test,
um,
the situation that seems wrong is actually okay.
Or what we say is it says,
oh,
this is a benign violation.
And when other people are laughing at something that you just said,
that might be a little bit off color.
What they're essentially saying is,
oh this is okay to me.
This is positive to me.
Right.
And you get these contagious effects.
It's like when some people will laugh after a statement.
That's not funny.
I guess I left the keys in home.
Yeah.
So they're trying to let you know I call no.
Yeah,
sorry.
And everyone's saying it's okay.
It's okay.
Yeah,
they're doing right.
Yeah.
So there's some lol.
What's interesting about about laughter is that it doesn't necessarily
communicate that,
that something's funny that it's been cooptive by language in a way that like,
so when people punctuate a sentence with laughter,
it's something they often don't even know they're doing and it's just a way to
kind of smooth the interaction versus the kind of what,
so that's what's called non dushane laughter,
Non Douchey Dushane Dushane 40 words.
Couldn't you come up with another type of design work?
Is that how it's pronounced?
Yeah.
He has no idea.
You were asking me do not answer Kim questions.
Trust me.
Keep the on.
So
you got sucked in.
I did a lot.
I was like,
I've said that word like 150 times.
Just got red band.
I hadn't fed him Red Van.
So the idea is,
is that you have like friends,
instance smiles,
a smile can be an indication of positive emotion or it could be like a sorority
girl,
girl smile.
That's like a fake smile.
The same could happen with laughter.
Right?
So I could politely laugh at a joke that you have that you've said just because
I exactly.
Trying to be nice.
So that doesn't indicate amusement.
Right?
Um,
but when it does like,
so like Ken obviously like most of the laughter that we have is that we've
actually enjoying something about a moment in time and,
but when other people are laughing,
it has that contagious effect.
So if you think about about laughter's a signaling tool,
it's useful if you want,
if you want to spread that signal out.
And so a low ceiling helps.
It helps get someone laughing who might not necessarily be laughing cause
they're just surrounded in laughter.
Right.
That makes sense.
Um,
so one of the things is having a dark room is really important,
is why the comedy store?
I think people really like the dark,
you know,
it's such a dark room.
Yeah.
It,
it disinhibit the audience.
So when you're in darkness,
you feel anonymous.
And,
and again,
if,
cause I believe that that comedy plays on,
on violations,
I'm talking about things that are wrong,
that are threatening,
that are amiss in some way.
Well,
most of the time those things aren't funny.
They make us laugh.
They make us,
excuse me.
They make us cry.
The anger us,
they,
they confuse us.
They discussed us and,
and they embarrass us.
And so when you're in,
but when you're in darkness,
you can let loose,
you won't hold back a laugh.
Laughter because you're like,
oh,
I can't,
I don't want to be the person who laughs at that kind of a joke.
And so it has this disinhibiting effect.
Uh,
some of the other things are like,
you know,
chairs having a chair that's,
that's kind of uncomfortable.
You know,
that in you're cramming people in,
it helps increase arousal.
Hmm.
So,
um,
because comedy plays on Arousal,
taking things that are kind of negatively arousing and making them positive.
And the,
the more arousing the situation is,
the bigger the emotional experience jamming people up together makes them
slightly uncomfortable because they're invading each other's space.
Yeah.
And you're just like more awake and more like uncomfortable.
And then another thing about jamming all these people together is you almost
create this bonding among them.
Yeah.
So I've had,
I've had comics talk about this idea of comedy as a conspiracy.
It's like,
it's like us versus them.
Like everybody in the room here,
we all get it.
And those fools out there,
they don't get it.
And when you're jammed in there with all these people,
you feel connected to them in a way that,
that I think often helps.
When you think,
you know what a lot of comics are doing,
he's just pointing out what's wrong with the world.
Um,
and,
and so now we have this bond.
We feel,
um,
we've,
we're highly aroused,
no one falling asleep during a comedy show.
You've got the laughter bouncing back down on people.
You've got the darkness.
And then the last thing is you've got the red brick wall behind the comic and
this,
I'm not sure how much of an effect this has,
but certain colors have that kind of more arousing like a red brick as it like
the behind me.
Yeah,
that,
that's a good arousal.
So the red is a more arousing color than blue fruit.
It's like flat red.
Why the brick?
No,
let's just make it like homey.
Is that what the idea is?
I don't know.
I think it's just,
there's just no,
it's not brick per se.
I don't know if there's anything about the bridge.
There's so many comedy clubs bring now.
Every improv has bricks.
They all have bricks.
Even if they don't have bricks,
they bring bricks in.
I think it's the red more than the brick,
although that's an interesting,
I could run that study.
Yeah,
I'm thinking about it.
I actually,
I paid to have these bricks put in.
These aren't even real bricks,
is that right?
Yeah.
The knee,
like that thing.
It's a veneer.
There's like,
why are they put down?
They,
they,
they do it.
But it makes me feel better while you're doing something real bricks,
but it's not all brick construction.
Like it's not going to stop the hulk from running through the wall.
I don't know why I said the hallway.
He's not real my point.
Don't think real brick stopped the whole no.
My point being,
I was wondering why,
um,
I think everything you said makes a lot of sense.
And one thing that I didn't even consider as the uncomfortable factor because is
a place called the Haha cafe that I love.
It's in north Hollywood,
great spot.
But they have couches in the front.
Uh,
people just like just lounge on the couch.
Now I'm thinking about it and I need them to listen to this podcast.
Like ditch the couches,
Kim,
some shitty fucking folding chairs,
slide them in there.
So the other one is that,
and this,
I haven't done the research on it,
but I believe it's the case.
It doesn't happen to comedy clubs that much,
but it happens like late night television.
You get those like freezing cold rooms.
Like Letterman is famous for like a 54 degree room or something like that.
And what you hear is people say,
oh,
it's because of the lights and the people are,
you know,
they're in these suits and they want to just keep it cold.
But I think it's also,
again,
it keeps the audience away because you're not gonna,
you're not going to nap when it's like 54 degrees,
you're,
you know,
you're uncomfortable in your,
you're awake.
Yeah.
I think he's dead right about that.
That totally makes sense as well.
I think another thing to take into consideration,
I don't know if you did,
um,
is that part of comedy?
Part of what's going on is it's like some sort of a mass hypnosis sort of a
thing when a guy's on stage and you really in the zone,
like he just,
he got your material like laid out and it's just,
you're just riding this fucking thing and the crowd is roaring and laughing
along with you.
There's,
they're letting you think for them almost.
It's like they're allowing you to have access to the wheel of their mind and you
take them on this crazy comedic journey.
And in that sense,
it's kind of like a mass hypnosis in a way.
And the smaller the area that you're doing this,
the more comfortable people are gonna feel allowing themselves to be taken away
like this.
Like when you have low ceilings,
the parameters are like very clearly defined.
Like there's a ceiling,
there's the floor,
here's the wall,
this is a small place.
But when you get a big place,
like when you're doing like our Madison Square Garden or an arena or someplace
with a giant ceiling,
people would say,
well,
I've got,
it's not a good place for comedy.
The laughs die,
wait,
this is a little bit of that.
But it's also like,
you know,
there's a lot above us.
There's a lot,
there's a lot of space here.
It's less comforting.
It's like,
it's less,
uh,
less contained than like say a place like the helium in Philadelphia where Joey
Diaz is this weekend.
Uh,
helium is one of the great comedy clubs in this country.
So it really low ceiling tight.
It's in,
you know,
this great neighborhood and it's just perfect.
Like you couldn't get any better.
It's like you're right on top of those people.
Like everything's the,
the entire dimension.
The dimension of the room are clearly defined.
Yeah.
I think,
um,
I,
I've called Madison Square Garden to have him let me run a study there and uh,
I haven't heard back from him yet,
so we'll see.
And I'll get right back to you.
I'm sure they're not busy on one free night this fall,
I think.
Um,
but it's very rare to see a comedian performed there though.
Oh,
I think it's,
yeah.
I mean these are,
cs is doing it.
They're,
Aziz has a gig there and I think,
um,
it actually might already had it.
Dane's done it.
Dice has done it.
I think there's only a small handful and it helps to have a lot of fans.
Right.
I think that those arena kinds of things,
these are people who already love that comedian and they're going to see them
help.
So it's also an event.
Yeah.
You know,
like,
uh,
if I give Kevin Hart showing up somewhere,
he's hot right now.
So that's an event.
We're going to go see Kevin Hart,
people at work,
even if they're not fans.
You guys get tickets for Kevin Hart herders.
Hilarious.
You know what I mean?
It's like such a big name thereof becomes an event.
Yeah.
That's interesting.
I think.
Well,
so the takeaway of all of this is I think you made a great choice for,
for rocky mountain high.
Oh,
Denver comedy works.
Yeah.
It's,
I mean,
every comedian I speak to talks about how that's in the top five.
Yeah.
Well Wendy,
who the woman who owns it and runs it,
he's like one of my favorite people ever and she's responsible essentially for
the entire comedy scene in Denver.
And she's,
she's,
she fosters it.
She developed this open mic program,
which brings people into,
into the club,
gives them time,
then make some like their middles and then they eventually she liked,
develops local headliners.
It's one of the few places left that has local headliners.
Oh,
that's nice.
Yeah.
I know the,
you know the graphics guys there,
they have a,
there's like a three man crew.
They do what?
They do their own show.
But they always are showing up at comedy.
No,
I don't know them.
Ben,
Roy,
Adam,
Kate and Holland.
Andrew orbital.
No,
no,
no.
You know like that.
Those are,
those are sort of,
yeah.
Now they're,
you know,
they're on the cusp.
This is a real scene there.
You know,
Denver is one of the few places that has a real scene.
That's what it takes.
It takes like a club.
And we've often talked about Houston because Houston is where Bill Hicks
started.
Where Sam Kinison started,
excuse me.
Houston in the early eighties was a motherfucker.
I mean it was a hotbed of talent but it was because of one club.
It's cause of the laptop,
laptop and river oaks.
And when that,
that's where I recorded my first ever CD in 1999 it was the first place I ever
like did well like on the road,
not did well.
It got laughs,
but like it would sell out every show.
And it was because they were like looking for that kind of comedy.
Like they had had,
you know,
Kinison started there and Carl Lebow,
the outlaws,
a comedy,
all those guys came out of Houston.
But when that club went away,
the scene went away.
Yeah.
You did any of those things.
So we,
for the humor code,
we,
we came to La to look at standup and Improv.
Um,
and we actually went to,
we went to New York and looked at the New Yorker cartoons.
Um,
so we,
and we,
um,
and also like humor and Madison Avenue and all that kind of stuff.
And then,
um,
we,
we actually went to Tanzania,
we went to Japan,
we went to the West Bank,
we went to Palestine,
Scandinavia,
the Amazon.
And what's interesting is,
I don't want to say standup is uniquely American cars.
Like in Japan,
they have like a vibrant comedy scene,
but it's,
it's different.
And so in Japan for instance,
they have two man comedy is called [inaudible] and it's like Dean and Martin
style stuff like an Abbott and Costello kind of a thing.
And they don't really have the comedy club,
like the independent comedy club scene.
It's all corporate in Japan for instance.
And uh,
you know,
it can in a lot of places,
like obviously in the Amazon,
there's like comedy clubs,
you know,
it's like,
it's such an interesting,
I mean is,
is it really does have,
have,
has had its start in the United States.
You know,
Wendy had this great conversation with a large chain that was trying to set up
in Denver.
Um,
and uh,
they wanted to talk to her about getting involved and she said,
what's your strategy as far as open Miker hers an open mic nights.
She was,
we're not going to have open Mike Nights.
She's like,
okay,
let me get this train.
You want to sell widgets,
but you don't want to make your own widgets,
but you're selling widgets but you don't develop widgets at all.
You know what I mean?
Any resources and developing,
which see other people have to bring you the widgets and they're like,
oh,
we didn't see it that way.
Right.
Know these,
like places like the Improv,
I do a lot of the Improv's,
but they don't do open mic nights.
And I think that's a huge disservice to the art form.
And to them it's just,
they don't,
they see it shortsightedly they see that as being a detriment to their business
because they're going to have to pay the wait staff and they might even lose
money on that night.
But I think that's how you develop talent.
And if you don't do that,
you don't develop talent and a scene and you get more people invested in the
idea standup comedy,
especially if you have like a local headliner guy,
it's really good people like really get involved in like someone who's like a
local person who's like really good [inaudible] who they think has potential to,
you know,
to break free or break it when it with a comb,
break in,
break out.
Yeah.
You know what I,
I,
I say how every,
every city has a rap star.
Hmm.
Right?
So should you go off to la or New York and try to create your fame and fortune
or do you become the best person in that city?
And so,
and I think of like,
I think of rap in that way.
Like you know,
so if you think about every major city,
not every but a lot of major cities,
you can identify who is the best and then they use that city as a leaping off
point for a more national scene and international scene.
And so on.
Wrap is very different than comedy though.
No,
no,
no.
But I mean,
but just as an analogy,
right?
The idea that you,
where is it that you should develop your craft?
When is it that you're ready to go to one of the coasts?
Like it sounds to me that if you have a good club of reasonable goal would be to
become the headliner,
lo local headliner,
add that club and then try to break into the business more broadly.
Like you know,
whether it be television or film or,
or go out on the road.
Yeah,
no,
you're just,
you,
you seem to be around other comics that kick ass.
It's a super important,
it's important every step of the way.
It needed to be around them hanging out and he'd be around them going onstage.
We feed off of each other.
We feed off of each other in a way that I don't think wrappers,
I mean,
I might be wrong,
but I don't think they have to as much because they can kind of judge themselves
on the little long history of rap nation wide and all of these places.
Well,
I,
yeah,
I mean I'm sure the development of the craft,
but the idea,
I guess the question is this is if you were a good comic and you wanted to get
great and you were going to prescribe a route for,
for one,
would you say,
looks,
you know,
stay in Denver and,
and be the best the Denver can offer and then do it.
Or when you think you're ready to head off to New York,
this is my advice and this is very general.
It could vary depending upon circumstances,
but I think you should get a general proficiency in a place where can get some
stage time.
Okay.
Like a Denver or Portland or a place.
It's a smaller place.
Yeah.
Get a general proficiency where you,
you know,
you're a general,
you're essentially a professional.
You can do a half an hour.
Okay.
Then get the fuck out of there.
Well I get out of,
I've got to go to la or New York because you gotta be around beasts.
You got to,
you got to see bill Byrd drop in to the comedy store in a Tuesday night and do
15 minutes.
You've got to see Joey Diaz go up in the original room at 11 o'clock and murder
the place.
You got to see those guys.
You gotta be around them,
you gotta,
you gotta.
There's a,
there's a certain inspirational heat that you get from being around a,
a crew of Comedians that takes your act to the next level almost universally.
So I,
I can,
I can see that.
It's hard to argue against that,
but if you're,
but you need to get the stage time right.
So it's this balance and if you're in Austin or Portland or Denver,
you do have great comics coming through all the time.
So you can get that sort of,
you know,
you can watch them do weekend sets that definitely,
and they do drop it,
but you won't see them working on material.
Yeah,
I see.
Seeing them working on material and when you know something's absolutely new,
there's like this spark of excitement that everybody has in the room,
like safe.
An event goes on,
like something happens in the news and then you know,
someone like Chris Rock will show up and start talking about that event.
It's like a certain crackle to that.
It's not the only thing that's necessary for success as a comedian.
Me,
you could absolutely be a guy who lives in Boise and goes on the road and does
great,
but there's something about being around a lot of really funny comedians that
has,
uh,
this undeniably inspirational effect.
Yeah,
I understand.
I mean,
I'm,
I,
I'm interested,
we were sort of were talking a little bit about this idea of like achievement,
right?
So what is it that predicts success in this very difficult business?
I'm certainly not,
I don't,
there's no hard,
fast answer.
There's no black or white,
you know,
I'm just saying from my point of view,
what I would advise,
and it's maybe my style and strategy is incorrect for some people.
I mean it would depend.
I would have to really know the person,
but some guys are fine.
Like living in Austin,
they develop a good little following and now because of the Internet you can get
a following just from a youtube video and then start touring nationally.
I think that's his,
that's essential as well.
I think touring is a,
another essential,
um,
developmental developmental tool for a comic.
Because I think one of the things about being a comic is you want to get the
most varied input possible.
If you're doing the same club all the time at the same kind of audience
preaching to the choir and you know the people that happened a lot in Boston,
in Boston,
a lot of the local guys,
they became really proficient and really good.
Boston people laugh.
Yes,
yes.
It was a huge trap.
And then they would go to other places and it would be like they were hamstrung.
Like someone had just like hit him in the kneecaps,
the baseball bat,
like they couldn't run anymore.
It was crazy to watch.
I see.
And that's exactly what it is.
It's not doing the road enough.
You have to develop an act that that is yours and then it's uniquely your,
you know,
your take on things.
But it also has your take on things is like a conglomeration of all the
experiences that you've had in your life and the more experiences that you have,
especially as a comic on stage in different places.
The more it flavors your performance and how you do it.
Yeah,
I think that's,
you know,
so people talk about this sort of 10 year rule,
that it takes 10 years to get your voice.
And um,
there,
you know,
obviously there's exceptions,
but you know,
I think some of it is just like you need the practice,
but some of that 10 years is you just come to better understand
the world.
Yeah.
Right.
And so,
so when you're 22 years old,
you,
you can be a funny person,
but it's,
but you haven't,
you know,
having to learn all the mechanics and all that kind of stuff.
You don't have enough material,
but some of it is you just don't really understand the world in the way that you
do when you're 32 or 42.
And,
um,
and what you're suggesting there was the more experience you have out on the
road understanding what people in Oklahoma find funny,
what people in Minnesota find funny,
what their lives are like and in Texas and Alabama and Atlanta ends up being
very useful because,
you know,
I mean I've been to the clubs in New York and La with the kind of like hipster,
audiences,
the all crowds.
Yeah.
And it's,
you know,
it's fun comedy but it's not going to go very far if you're interested in going
far.
Well it's,
it's a very specialized form of comedy.
Like you're the cool guy in the room,
you know,
and the cool guy in the back of the room recognizes the cool guy in the room and
you're pushing a lot of progressive issues that,
you know,
are very debate,
debatable in other parts of the country.
But you know,
you're just getting like a raucous round of applause and appreciation for what
you're saying.
And then you feed off of that and then you become like super captain,
lefty and you going on stage with the Fedora on talking about being a feminist
and you know it's a lot of what they're doing is just,
you know,
that's their spot.
They're doing Boston comedy,
they're just doing it in Brooklyn and some hipster spot.
You know what I mean?
Like by saying Boston comedy,
I mean,
I mean they're doing like a specific style of comedy that maybe they like or
maybe works well and their area.
And then there's nothing wrong with doing that.
I mean,
you could do that.
That could be your thing.
You can do whatever the fuck you want.
But I think that one of the great things about being a comic is going to all
these weird places and you know,
doing standup in Alaska,
doing stand up in Florida,
doing stand up all over the place and experiencing all these weird things and
weird crowds and weird situations.
If you just did comedy only in Brooklyn,
I think you're going to get a very limited perspective.
You're going to get a very,
your,
your art's not going to reach its full potential,
if that makes any sense.
Pretentious calling it art.
No,
no,
no.
I actually,
well I think,
I think it can be art.
Yeah.
You know,
I mean,
um,
you know,
fart jokes aren't artistic though.
They might get laughs cause you can make laughs and change the way people see
the world or if the fart jokes is so fucking good that it literally transcends
the fart joke genre and it becomes art that's possible right now.
Send me an email when that happens.
I'd like to,
but I'm going to put,
I'll start paying attention.
But um,
so you know,
actually,
but for the humor code,
that's exactly the perspective that we took.
So one of the things that we did was say,
and this is no offense to you,
we said,
well,
um,
humorous,
not just stand up.
Stand up is a,
is a bizarre art form.
You know,
that,
that it,
it seems like the quintessential thing that you should look at.
But most of our laughs don't come from a guy on a stage with a mic.
And a fedora.
It's from,
you know,
our,
our own interactions with our friends and our family and strangers and watching
television,
watching film and,
you know,
like seeing,
seeing the world more broadly.
And,
and then also,
um,
it's such a complex topic.
We were like,
oh,
we can't just look at it in the United States.
We can't be.
So I'm so focused on the u s and that's what pushed us to go out and look at
this.
Like,
so we,
we went to the West Bank and hung out with this comedy satire troop.
Whoa.
Who has a television show that it's,
it's once a week,
but during Ramadan it's every single night for 30 nights.
And so,
whoa.
Um,
yeah.
And so like,
we hung out with these folks.
Like,
so these are people who are there living in the West Bank and they're
criticizing everyone.
So they're criticizing the Palestinians,
Israel,
the Israelis,
the Americans,
Barack.
Um,
wow.
Uh,
you know,
like Osama and Obama in the same sketch,
right?
Like the,
you know,
these guys are doing really cutting edge stuff in this place that there,
there aren't comedy clubs like your,
the way that you get professional comedy,
there's like two shows on Palestinian national television or you need to find it
broadcast from Egypt or from Jordan or,
I'm not sure Jordan,
because evidently the Jordans aren't terribly funny.
Jordanians are very funny.
But the Egyptians are like rule areas.
Jordanians are funny guy right now listening.
It's fucking pissed.
There's a no,
we talked to these guys and they're like,
oh yeah,
there's a,
there's like a hierarchy of comedy in the Middle East.
And according to them,
the Palestinians are about the middle.
The Egyptians are hilarious.
Really.
And the Jordanians evidently are like the most serious.
They're very funny.
Yes.
I can't remember.
I don't know.
Uh,
it was,
Joel was here.
He remembers everything,
you know,
cause he writes it all down.
But uh,
yeah,
there's like a long history of,
uh,
of Egyptian comedy.
Ha.
Very funny people.
What about,
uh,
the Israelis do they factor in there?
Yeah.
So,
so what was really fascinating was that,
um,
so we,
you know,
you have kind of the stereotype of the,
of the,
the funny Jewish person,
right?
Very self deprecating.
Um,
but you don't find that style of comedy in Israel as much.
The Israeli,
um,
comedies a lot more aggressive.
Like it's the,
it's the comedy of the victor not of the,
of the victim.
Oh,
how's chance?
So we found this weird reversal where the Palestinians were much more sort of
self deprecating and their comedy was much more Jewish in the American sense
then you would have necessarily expected.
So it was real.
I was really fascinating.
That's so strange that it is weird when you think about,
I've met a bunch of Israelis and they're very different from a lot of the
American Jews.
And I think that that's a big generalization.
American Jews,
sorry folks.
But the,
the idea being that they're at war all the time.
I mean,
they're constantly surrounded by people who hate them.
They all have mandatory military service.
How did,
did you study how like the American Jew came to be like the separate subspecies
of the Jew?
You know,
like sort of like the Sitka blacktail deer.
It's a smaller deal lives in Alaska.
One thing that we've looked at was how overrepresented Jewish Americans are in
comedy.
And so like back in the day it was like 70% like it was,
it was an incredible number.
Now it was less so now.
But um,
those folks have been replaced by,
by other minorities.
So African Americans even like the rise of the Muslim American comedian post
nine 11,
you're seeing this and what,
what I think it is is that to be a minority is advantageous when it comes to
creating jokes because,
um,
what,
you know,
what you're doing as I like to say is you're trying to create benign violations.
You're trying to make things that are wrong.
Okay.
Well being a minority helps identify what's wrong in the world because when you
have one foot in the majority culture and one foot outside of it,
you can see the things that seem off right.
Strange.
Like it's sort of like by Chris Rock.
I think one of the brilliant things about Chris rock is the,
has crossover appeal.
And,
and some of it was that he went to a white high school,
so he was sort of too black for a white high school,
but then back in his neighborhood,
he was sort of too much of a nerd,
right?
Like he was,
he never fit in either of those places.
And so he could see what was wrong at home and he could see what was wrong with
white culture in a way that when you just buy in totally,
you don't see those things that are wrong.
And here's the things that are wrong is what's the right source of comedy.
And so,
so if you think about Jewish Americans,
while they fit that model very nicely in a number of different dimensions,
right?
So like culturally,
religiously,
and you know,
and so on,
um,
ethnically and so on.
And so,
and then,
and now you also have mentors,
right?
So,
um,
so if you,
if you're like looking for someone to look up to,
you can find someone who's like you,
right?
You've got Mel Brooks making,
you know,
making his way in,
um,
in comedy in a way that,
uh,
is inspirational.
And you see it as like,
oh,
I can do cause smells done
it or right.
Right.
And so on.
So,
but we haven't gone,
that's about as deep as we went with it.
But it's a really fascinating idea.
This,
this notion of um,
WB Dubois caught it Tunis,
right?
So you have like kind of two identities.
That's,
that's a useful thing.
It's why like,
it's like you're talking like we were talking about Mexico City in Mexico City.
That's just the way the traffic is.
But you come there as an outsider and it just seems so bizarre.
Um,
Mexican person comes to La and they make,
they make jokes about la traffic,
about how well behaved people seem to be,
at least relative to home.
You know,
you can see how that stuff can,
yeah.
I talked to my friend who's from Mexico and she was laughing and she was like,
they always say,
if you could drive in Mexico City,
you can drive anywhere.
You know?
She's like I was saying,
I can't believe what the traffic is like down there.
She's like,
I know I came to America,
I could drive easy.
No problem.
You should go to,
we went to Denmark and it's the easiest driving in the world.
Like we rented a car,
drove all over the place in Denmark.
They just so polite.
It's polite rule abiding everything.
And also there's like nobody there like,
you know,
like we're in Copenhagen and just like where is everybody?
Well in that place,
that's how boulder is.
Boulders,
very polite.
Like the driving there is very calm and I know and I want to start honking.
It's like don't do it.
People peep.
Here's the problem is,
is people are too polite at times and as a result people misbehave because they,
they don't,
they feel like they're operating in like with anonymity because they've come
from probably a place where people like are a little bit more aggressive and,
and so I'm like,
I need to start using it.
I'm from New Jersey originally.
I don't do it.
Don't bring Jersey to fucking bolden.
Don't do it dude.
God Damn you.
Damn.
You beat him across.
Um,
what you're saying about the outsider,
it makes a ton of sense.
Especially being outside or on both sides.
It'll be an or inside the black community and of course being black,
being outside or in the white communities for Chris Rock.
Yeah,
that totally makes sense.
Being in an outsider,
having some,
you know,
having a lack of comfort,
I mean it's almost like what we were talking about,
about being squished in together and being cold and like there's something about
a lack of comfort that can create comedy.
The Jew thing is fascinating to me because Europeans like it's complimentary.
P and Jews are so intelligent,
like they have a completely disproportionate number of Nobel prize winners that
are European Jews.
Um,
they,
they're responsible for a great deal of like inventions and,
and innovation.
It's incredible.
Like just as far as like European Jews,
you look at the,
the intellectual talent pool,
it's come out of Europe,
Jewish folks from Europe.
It's amazing.
And a lot of those who immigrated to America became fantastic.
Standup comedians were known like pretty much across the board as being like
really intelligent.
Yeah.
Like you think about like,
I mean woody Allen before all of his troubles was known as a very intelligent
guy.
And a very introspective and fascinating guy.
Jerry Seinfeld is of course known as being very intelligent.
That means is there's a slew of them.
You can just start there.
And Larry David,
he can go on to the end of time.
So the best predictor of a good sense of humor is intelligence.
And so,
um,
so some like in the professional ranks that that clearly makes sense because you
have to be writing,
you know what I mean?
Like,
so you're,
so you have to,
um,
to be good at,
at writing and putting these things together.
But even outside of the professional ranks,
just to be quick witted it helps to be smart because really what you're doing is
creating a situation where you take this thing that seems wrong and find a way
to make it okay.
And,
and smart people tend to be more creative and smart people tend to be better at
that kind of thing.
It's like,
it's really is the best.
I mean,
you don't have to be,
cause you know,
you can still make fart jokes and so on,
but you've got a problem with fuck fart jokes.
Did I see what you're doing.
You get caught in a trap and you get caught in a trap.
Here's that trap.
The trap is you eliminate a subject matter because he believe it's low brow.
Okay.
But the reality is there are certain times but that is the correct thing to
discuss.
Sure.
And you know Ari Shaffir has this joke about having diarrhea and he had to go
across this bridge in Sydney.
We were in Australia.
I'm already laughing.
It's true story.
And his manager actually told him,
look Ari,
it's a shit joke and it's all fucking hilarious pit.
His marriage is like,
look man,
you got to drop that.
It's a shit joke.
So he dropped his manager said fuck off dummy.
Like you don't know.
You're talking about like there's certain times where that is the right thing to
talk about.
I agree.
I mean,
you know,
if you give a comic a choice between saying something smart and things,
something that gets laughs,
they go with the labs they and they ought to.
That's the currency they trade in.
But now see that,
I discussed this on reddit yesterday.
Now that comics have podcasts,
if they have like something that they really want to discuss is not funny at
all.
They can do it on a podcast,
but there was like a real trap that some comics would get into.
Like when they started getting a little bit of relevance,
especially when they would start preaching onstage and it's gross.
Like they would say things on stage that aren't funny at all to get applause
breaks to get people to agree with Doug a tedtalk almost.
Or like,
you know,
you're essentially preaching to the choir.
I mean that's what you're doing.
You're near you.
You're doing it on purpose to like to set yourself up on a moral high ground or
to establish a premise.
You know,
and then you're going to expand from there.
But it's,
the preaching thing gets really fucking gross when you're an audience member,
especially if it's like Duh,
like a really obvious stuff that you know someone's doing just to get.
Like,
of course,
we all think that women shouldn't be slaves.
You know what I mean?
Women shouldn't be slaves.
You know,
everybody starts clapping like,
what are you doing?
If you don't have a punchline,
don't say that.
Of course women shouldn't be,
nobody should be a fucking slave.
You know?
It's like that kind of thing is avoided by podcasts because in podcasts you can
explore an idea and not having to worry about like the very rigid parameters of
like getting a joke or getting a laugh every x amount of seconds.
I see.
And then you can have people like me on getting,
we didn't have people that are way less funny.
You actually got laughs on stage at a comedy club.
You know,
I've had like theoretical physicists on where you have to ask them to repeat
themselves because you don't know what the fuck they just said or you know,
really intellectual people with very varied interests.
That's where it's not funny at all and you don't have to be,
there's other you're providing other,
it's not even that you're providing,
it's a conversation.
That's all it is.
Like when you have a conversation,
if you're the type of guy that is trying to get laughs all the time,
when you have any conversation,
you're going to fucking really boring conversations cause you're going to limit
your interaction to only like that little narrow gap of humor.
You can't go deep on stuff.
You can't mean look,
even when you go deep,
that's the other thing.
Sometimes you're going deep,
but there's still some ridiculously funny shit in the deepness,
you know,
and you can,
we're human.
We're pliable.
We can go back and forth between all of them.
The idea that you can only be one or the other is like a marketing issue or
something.
I see.
All right.
I'll,
I'm brace the Fart joke.
That's why don't you write though for the most part,
most of the time when someone tells a Fart joke,
they're only telling a fart joke because they,
they're just scared and they're trying to get a laugh and it's almost insulting
as an audience member.
It's a cheap laugh.
Yeah.
Although it's still a laugh.
Right.
And he said,
if you have the choice between no laughing a cheap laugh.
I don't know.
I saw Joey Diaz fart until microphone once the comedy store.
It was one of the funniest things ever saw my life cause he was,
he was totally non related and he's like,
I'm sorry I got to Fart knee.
He just farted right into the microphone.
I would live to see his face during a Tiffany Haddish.
Queef yeah.
You don't want to see that it was a girl.
She always do this.
Yeah.
There's um,
there's this girl who,
uh,
does stand up and one of her big is she makes a air come out of her vaginal
cavity and makes noises with it and puts the microphone up to her crotch.
Unique skill.
It's so funny.
I don't know if it's unique,
but it's unique that she's willing to do it on stage with a microphone.
You know,
and it's great because he did it at the end of her set,
so she's all sweaty and said it's more of a wet one.
It says like,
oh my goodness.
Yeah,
he's 40
grown man.
Um,
yeah.
Would follow her on Twitter or on the road.
Oh,
your friends.
I have to follow her and using the microphone right after.
And you told joke about that.
No,
I,
that's how that's you open.
It still smells a little one quickie.
That's not funny.
You should come up with a better joke.
Um,
yeah,
that was a show stopper.
Yeah,
that's him.
That's what he does.
Sometimes it's not good like right there.
Um,
but the point being,
it's like funny.
It's funny and sometimes someone will say something that you would say,
oh,
you shouldn't do jokes on that.
Like Ari's joke about shitting his pants while he's going over the bridge.
Yeah.
But yeah,
he should.
I mean it's,
it was,
it was a clever bit.
It's a funny,
honest bit and it's,
it is what it is.
And I think that,
um,
there's been a lot of like bad comedy on almost every subject.
You know,
there's been a lot of bad comedy on Fart jokes are a lot of bad comedy on,
you know,
fill in the blank,
like airplane jokes.
Like if you have an airplane,
Joe.
Yeah,
that's right.
I always hear comics talk about that like enough with the travel jokes,
you know,
cause it's just every comic has a travel job.
But if someone comes along with a travel joke that just knocks your socks off,
that is what it is.
You know,
someone can have a point or a point of view or a take on some aspect that we
hit.
You haven't considered some unique aspect,
you know?
Uh,
yes.
But I mean,
well so it's like it's yes,
but isn't it,
I mean it's really is the thing where you,
you are trying to be unique,
right?
The ideal situation is you say stuff that no one saying that they're not
thinking about the way you're thinking about it,
that you're giving people a perspective that doesn't quite seem familiar.
That's the,
that's the holy grail I think.
Um,
and especially in a world where it's so hard to stand out.
I mean,
I constantly have people say,
Oh,
do you know this particular comic?
And I'm like,
no,
I don't.
And that person is very good.
It's just,
there's so many of them.
And so how is it that you can,
you know,
get people's attention and,
and,
and I mean,
I hate to use the marketing term,
but like cut through the clutter,
but isn't that the sort of the,
the case with any art form?
Like with music?
I mean there's so many small bands,
I know bands that are trying to make it and yeah,
I mean any of the entertainment world of entertainment,
I think that's,
that's probably the case.
But I think that today,
at least it's the best time to be one of those people.
They'd be like,
especially like bands because of Youtube.
Cause now,
yeah.
Yeah.
Now you don't have to rely on the machinery.
I mean that's the thing that I think is really exciting about comedy,
um,
specifically and in entertainment in general is that now you have the long tail,
right?
Like,
because it's a big world.
There's 300 million people in the United States and now there's like some kid in
Kansas City who never would have found your,
found you or you know,
and then he stumbles upon you and he hears about it and,
and then you can actually create a following through technology because you're
just cutting out the middleman.
You don't need,
you know,
you,
you just don't,
you don't need the,
um,
the,
and you don't need
the clubs and you don't need all these things as much because you can reach
people directly and so then you can be,
you can,
you can be really narrow,
um,
because there's enough people out there who might be able to support that.
Yeah,
sure.
That's really exciting.
Yeah.
Well there's,
especially like when you talk about like specific genres,
like all comedy,
all comedy scenes,
all over the country now where you could,
you know,
you could fit in,
in these areas because there's a lot of people that like,
like a different style of comedy,
just like there's a lot of people that like a different style of music.
That's the weird thing about comedy is that the genre itself is not really
defining of what it is.
It's like you don't go to see live music.
You go to see live rock and roll.
You go to see live blues,
live country.
Even if you don't know the artists,
you essentially go to a club where you know what they're,
what they're selling.
Yeah,
that's a good point.
But comedy,
man,
you can get guns and roses or you get Barry Manilow and back to back,
back to back.
Well,
the comedy store,
you'll deal with like 10 comics in a night and they're all totally different.
I mean,
there's all sorts of different takes,
you know,
I'm really impressed by is these,
uh,
sort of blue collar comedy guys,
because what they've done is found a space that's,
there's a huge demand for,
and there's not enough people filling it.
Right,
right.
You know,
so if you think about it,
like you've got all these alt comics and they're all,
they all look like they came from Mumford and sons.
They're all the sort of the same dude.
Yeah.
And you're just like,
and now they're,
they're just competing so much and then like these blue collar guys just must be
killing it because there's a whole world out there that's not producing enough
comics for the demand.
Well,
I have a friend who's really into country music and I was over his house and
they were watching the country music channel.
It's fucking ridiculous.
It was all country music videos and it's like,
it was so some the worst music you'll ever hear in your life.
But it's like this culture that they're ingrained in and there's not a lot of
comedians that connect to that culture now.
But it's like,
have you ever seen the compilation Brion pull up this compilation,
why country music sucked in 2013?
It's fucking hilarious cause it's,
it's,
it's about what we're talking about.
We're talking about like hack premises and obvious scenarios and there's formula
to success that's insulting to people that like,
uh,
if you enjoy like Merle haggard and enjoy like some really good countries,
Hank Williams,
you know,
uh,
Waylon Jennings,
you know that the real shit man and that Johnny Cash and you listened to some of
this like really obvious,
obvious formulaic sort of created shit and it's,
it's,
it's annoying.
I could drive you crazy so that somebody's concocted this video of all,
all of the premises in country music and how much they're repeated and how often
they're repeated.
Did you find it?
Yeah,
I think so.
I do a youtube video.
Okay.
Do you think it's going to get his boat?
Uh,
yeah.
Play it on that thing and then just we'll walk.
We'll watch it.
You can do that,
right?
What's the worry?
We get pulled from youtube all the time.
Youtube,
uh,
someone would make a claim against you.
Say like,
if we,
if we just do the show,
we're fine.
You do the show and we show a video and the video is like,
like a snake eating a crocodile or something like that.
Somebody owns that video and then we get pulled from youtube.
If you get a certain amount of strikes,
if you get pulled for copyright violation a certain amount of times,
we always take down the video and then edit it out and put it back out.
It happens a certain time.
You can get in trouble like this.
Why country music was awful in 2013 and this is particularly awesome for me
because this is going to be cliches.
It's just cliche,
aspirin,
glorious,
glorious series of cliches,
but it just shows you how,
how hard people are not trying or how hard they're trying to do the same.
You don't have to try as hard like that's,
that ends up being an open question though.
No.
Okay.
Here's how country music worked.
In 2013 a bunch of dudes sang about trucks.
This is good comedy.
Oh,
they drove down old dirt roads.
Here's the quote.
We're rolling
and they begged girls getting their trucks too.
You're a little hot
in here.
The only one at girls wearing tight jeans,
those
genes,
those genes just,
it's so crazy.
And they drove the girls to the nearest river bank,
river hooker.
The moonlight made it all.
So Romance,
tick
and there was always alcohol,
Aka good stuff to loosen things up.
Yeah.
Good stuff is moonshine.
Oh
stone and chill in the drain.
But if every borough tactic failed,
they would just call their girl girl.
Hey,
good
girl.
Quiet listening to country music.
Well not that,
that's not the whole genre.
It's most of it though,
right?
There's an appetite dot.
Well it's like,
just like saying music is like that.
I mean there's a lot of God damn pop music cause most music pop music,
honey honey is obviously not pop music.
There's a lot of music does not pop music.
It's just sees it as a joke about this.
Right?
Think about these sort of Cla like these sort of club songs about partying and
yeah,
he has a,
I haven't seen it all this stuff,
but it's,
I mean he's just doing it now with like club music,
new stuff.
Yeah,
no it's not.
It's a few years old.
Oh,
is it?
But you know,
the idea is that you're finding these things that resonate.
People like it and so people keep doing it.
It's just different versions of it all.
What does a market,
you know,
especially when you're talking about like going out to like clubs and drinking,
like drinking in clubs and playing music while people are drinking,
like shot,
shot,
people love that kind of stuff.
They love to,
to be included.
But you know,
this is just like,
you could clear that off man,
clear all that and go back to the blank screen.
It's all a hack premises,
you know?
It's like that's a,
that's one of the things like,
you know,
don't do fart jokes,
don't do,
you don't do anything low brow.
Don't do anything so obvious unless you want to get paid.
Right.
I mean that's like there's a bit of that.
No,
it was a little bit of that,
especially in the beginning.
I think with comedy,
one of the things in the beginning is just becoming at least reasonably
proficient.
And the way I was describing that,
there's like three steps.
The first,
and sometimes they're not all necessary.
The second step is fine,
but the first step is you just figure out what works.
It's like you have a toolbox.
It's like you're just hammering nails and sawn wood.
You're just trying to figure out what works.
So your jokes,
you might not even think they're funny at all,
but they get a,
so you stick with them.
Okay.
And then once you get good enough,
you start doing stuff that you actually think is funny.
And then the third step is you start trying to make your ideas funny.
Like make points.
Some people don't ever get there.
That is the end of some of the best ones.
Don't ever get like Mitch Hedberg is my perfect example.
If a guy who was like one of my all time favorite Comedians,
okay.
But he never had,
like there was no philosophy behind his comedy.
It was just a,
it was just really hilarious.
One liners non-related one liners to an hours of them.
You know,
he was a really unique and unusual comic in that sense.
Did he,
did he recreate himself at one point in his career?
Like the Mitch Hedberg that everybody knows about is not,
he didn't start doing that style.
Like even like the kind of cadence and the way he,
I think he changed his voice.
Am I know that I'm not true three now.
He pretty much always start that.
Yeah,
I've known,
I knew him for a long time.
Miss uh,
miss miss read something.
Well,
one thing that did happen is he got development deals and they started doing
like the whole sitcoms shuffle thing with them trying to develop a sitcom form.
And then once they stopped developing the Sitcom,
then he like didn't work out.
The acting thing didn't work out and he really started just touring more and
getting more into a standup in a standup.
She's kept getting stronger and stronger and stronger and it led to the Mitch
Hedberg that everybody knows now.
Okay,
I see.
Alright.
But there's also substance abuse involved in there.
Like a lot of it and that there's,
there's some of his style that you could probably attribute to drugs,
you know,
because he had this heroin issue,
and he had this sort of almost they bag heroin style.
I took a piece of carefree gum and hour later I was still worried it never
kicked in.
You know,
he had this weird like slick,
bizarre style of comedy that I mean huge loss back.
I wonder like where would he,
where could he have gone?
Cause he's still been using the same thing.
He would have been doing the same thing and we've been just,
he had no like dull spots.
Like if you go and look at through his body of work was no like bad stuff.
I think it's like it started off great.
It stayed great to the,
to the very end.
He would create new great stuff.
And in my opinion,
the hardest way to do it.
Like the one liners like unrelated one liners over and over again.
It's,
and especially like bizarre absurdist sort of one liners.
Yeah.
But you know,
more people would have known about them for sure.
I mean,
he died I think in 2000 and I want to say three somewhere around them before
the,
I mean,
because his stuff,
it's perfect youtube material.
Yes.
Yeah.
It's like so shareable.
You know what I mean?
Like in,
and you can you,
because it's one liners,
you can break it down and have like 15 seconds or 15 minutes.
People eat it up.
He's an interesting guy too because there's a lot of,
um,
stories about him in the early days where club owners didn't quite get it.
Like when you go on the road,
a lot of times
the club owner just cares about putting a,
an,
you know,
an act on stage.
It's going to get labs and sometimes the act that they'll book for the
headliner's not compatible.
Okay.
Like he worked with some guy and the guy was like singing and doing impressions
of musicians doing fucking flips and cartwheels and shit.
And then,
you know,
he had this crazy big closer that he would do.
Thank you.
Good night.
Everybody would go crazy.
And then Mitch Hedberg would go onstage with his sunglasses on and people would
get angry.
And it,
it didn't just happen in one club.
It happened in a bunch of clubs.
And obviously you're talking about the guy who I think is like one of the best
ever.
But he would eat shit because he would go on after these guys and no one knew
who he was.
So they didn't know.
They didn't know that they were going to expect the Mitch Hedberg style.
So they saw this guy go on after this guy who was flipping around and sweating
and putting out all this effort and they just never look like he's mailing it
in.
Maybe they just couldn't switch gears.
You know,
you know,
this is,
this is a really interesting idea.
Like,
so this is the kind of stuff that I,
I test for a living.
Right?
So,
so what we've been sort of talking about is like,
whether someone's funny or not,
or how they develop,
you know,
a sense of humor,
the ability to produce lasts than others.
But from the comedy club conversation that we had earlier,
and in this conversation you realize that there's a lot of moving parts,
right?
There's a lot of things that are outside of your control as someone trying to be
funny.
And so the idea that you could have someone who was very,
I mean,
ideally you do have someone who is funny before you because it warms the crowd
up and they're already in a good mood and they're just more likely to laugh now
than they were before because they're,
they're,
you know,
their mood state has changed,
it's positive and so on.
But the fact is,
is that that,
that,
that can have such a profound effect shows that there's a lot of like contextual
factors that are at play that you can't necessarily control.
You know?
And so that's,
I've never,
uh,
yeah.
So what I,
I tried to put my finger on what would be the contrast there?
Like why is it that the audience would sort of rebel against him given how good,
I mean,
you know,
he's good.
So Scott algae to music.
I mean if,
if Metallica went onstage and did you know a,
a concert in front of a bunch of metal fans and went fucking crazy,
did enter Sandman and then brought up Christina Aguilera.
Yeah.
How well do you think that would go
mad?
A bitch?
No.
But
you know,
if you would,
if you go to any sort of a,
a music show,
it's very rare that you have like a completely contrasting styles like that they
share the same stage.
The difference.
So
is that this is presumably like just a regular like it's not is
it wasn't an audience to came there for this jumping around guy.
Right,
right,
right.
No,
it was just a comedy club.
Yeah,
that's right.
That's the thing.
And that's the difficult part of the developing as a comedian.
I think for a lot of comics it's like you have to find your audience and if you
compromise yourself,
you don't ever find your audience.
You become this sort of middle of the road guy with a blazer on.
Like when I first tried to go on stage,
the first thing I did is try to dress like comedian.
So I wore a blazer and I rolled my sleeves up and I wore like a wacky tee shirt
and it had like a pin on my jacket.
Like I was trying to like fit into the mold of what I thought of a comedian.
And I think that if you're a comic it's very hard to become a Mitch Hedberg
because of that.
It's very hard to like do something that no ones,
they haven't seen the why is he wearing sunglasses?
Like why is he,
he would turn his back to the crowd,
do like his,
his act to the wall.
Sometimes we'd hide behind curtains.
He would do his whole act behind the curtain.
I'm just going to hang out back here for a little bit.
And he would do his act like that creates around,
yes,
it's unusual destination.
We look at it to browse and creating arousal and the key is just to make sure
that the Arrow is pointed to the positive side cause cause that makes,
it would make it even worse.
Like if he was bombing,
yeah,
that would make it even worse because now he's creating negative around.
Exactly.
Yeah.
I mean he was doing well and doing that,
but like I,
I've told this story before but it's a bears repeating a hicks.
I saw Hicks in Boston and I saw him bomb and uh,
he went on after a guy who's a like really hacky,
like the guy was doing like cartoon characters smoking.
We like doing impressions of like things that we all knew,
you know,
like just standard really like down the middle hacky shit.
And he did well Hicks went off from,
no one knew who fuck Hicks was in.
Hicks just ate shit for like 45 minutes except for like 50 people in the room.
So it was like a 300 seat room,
250 people leave.
The fifth 50 people that are remaining are howling laughing.
It's like the comics in the back of the room and like a few people in the
audience.
But Hicks never like left that style.
Like he keys and he knew this wasn't as crowd and he just plowed through it
anyway.
And found his crowd in the people that stayed because he never stopped like
delivering the material the way he wanted to do it.
And it was,
it was very unusual because I'd never seen a guy be so confident bombing.
So this idea,
um,
so the theory that we use is benign violation theory.
One of the Nice things about the theory is that explains the two ways that a
humor attempt can fail.
So you are trying to find that sweet spot,
the situation being wrong yet.
Okay.
Sometimes you create a situation that's just wrong and people are outraged and
sometimes you create a situation that's just okay.
And people were bored.
And so,
so when I,
when I bombed,
when I tried to stand up,
I bombed on the benign side.
My jokes,
they didn't go far enough.
I had an audience of like dirt bag hipsters and want to be comedians.
And so the jokes I was telling where they were just too boring and benign cause
that night people were talking about smoking crack and about abortions and all
these kinds of things that were like,
you know,
just much more savory.
Unsavory.
Thank you.
Risque.
But um,
but what you can find is that three people can have three different reactions to
the same joke.
So one person is howling with laughter,
one person is totally outraged and the other person is like,
come on,
tell me something funny.
And so what that shows you is that in any one audience and the more
heterogeneous the audiences,
the more diverse the audience is,
the more likely you're going to get all three of those reactions.
And ideally what you do,
what Hicks did was find the people who he hits the sweet spot with.
And then,
you know,
nowadays imagine what you know,
uh,
what,
see what happens.
Is it like now you can identify who your audience is and they can find out where
you are that you don't just stumble into a club anymore.
They people go to see Joe Rogan cause they know that,
that he's going to be funny to them even though you know you're not,
no offense,
you're not for everyone.
No what he is,
that's the key.
If you,
you know,
if you try to be funny for everybody,
you're never going to figure out what the fuck is unique about what you do,
your sense of humor,
your style of,
of looking at the world.
And I think that's a big part of what comedy is a big pop part of a comedy has
is here's the world through my eyes.
But if it's not really,
here's the rest of my eyes,
here's the world through the vision that I think you would laugh at.
That's not,
that's not like really your take on things.
And would hicks had figured out,
I guess long before a lot of people was just a stick to your guns and they'll
find you,
you know,
the,
the fucking field of dreams build it and they'll come.
And it's your funny though,
like a fun thing because there are plenty of people stick to their guns,
right?
They just don't have an audience.
That's a true,
that's the true statement,
right?
There's,
there's so many variables involved.
And like some people would listen to that country music thing and they would
love each one of those songs individually and can't wait until they come on the
radio again.
And they're not wrong.
They're not wrong.
It's a taste issue.
It's like what you were saying about the blue collar guys,
it's like they figured out how to tap into that,
that sort of unrepresented aspect of America,
which is monstrously huge,
huge.
I mean it's like you find out how many albums are being sold of country music
albums,
how many people know that music and it's,
it's incredible.
It's like you're dealing with a whole different world that you didn't know
existed.
Yes.
And Larry,
the Cable Bot,
Larry the cable guy rather owns that world.
Like that guy does football arenas.
You know,
I,
um,
I've got serious on my,
in my car and I,
and there's like six stations you can,
you know,
you can choose from comedy,
comedy stations.
Thank you.
Yeah.
And uh,
I regularly try to listen to the blue collar station because it's,
while it's different and it's like,
it's good comedy.
Larry.
The cable guy's a funny,
very smart guy.
Yeah.
He's a very good comic.
That's why I was,
I'm shocked when a lot of people were like,
a lot of people were like super jealous I guess,
or they felt like he represented racism or homophobia or whatever it was his
character did.
And so like a lot of people,
like we're really derogatory about it.
I'm like,
are you ever like read his jokes are listened to his jokes?
Yeah.
They're well written jokes.
It's a character.
His name's Dan Whitney.
Yeah.
Okay.
I mean it's,
he's doing an act.
I mean,
I think about that like with dice clay,
you know,
like,
you just,
you,
you have a character and you create a character that can work when you're really
funny though.
If he said he got to a certain point,
it was like,
okay,
I got enough money.
It's time to start turning on these mother fuckers.
He's
using his character to expose like the worst aspects of southern life and
religious ignorance.
And you know,
it could be fascinating.
You know who the other person who I think of is,
is a Russell Peters.
In what way?
That he,
um,
that he's found a niche.
Oh yeah.
I mean,
and like a space like there,
you know,
it was like Indian people want to laugh and so like,
uh,
and he's very good.
I mean,
you know,
all this stuff is all contingent on being very good.
Yes.
By very much so.
But the opportunities there are just huge.
Well,
Russell transcends,
I mean,
he doesn't,
I'm,
a lot of people know him from Youtube has youtube clips or giant,
like he has youtube clips with millions of hits and that's really what made him
big.
And he like,
if you go to one of his shows,
it's not just Indian folks here.
Like you'll find people of all ethnicities because he does so much on race and
he's so likable,
you know,
he's so likable and he has good points and you know,
he's just a friendly,
smiley guy up there.
You like,
you want to,
you want to enjoy him.
Yes,
that's true.
Yeah.
He's the fucking nicest guy ever to like real life.
He's a sweetheart.
Like you'll never hear any,
I've never heard anybody say anything bad about Russell,
you know,
but so when Russell tells you someone's a Douche bag and you go,
hmm,
I bet that person's really a Duisburg.
Oh Wow.
But I mean,
he sold out the o two arena in London twice.
Yeah.
He's giant.
Been a lot of that.
I'm sure a lot of his Asian folks,
you know,
folks from India and all sorts of people,
all sorts of different ethnicities.
But he definitely found a mark market
in the humor code.
One of the things that that stands out is that no matter where you go,
people value laughs.
Like they,
you know,
they value it in their,
in their personal lives.
They valued in their leisure time.
They're there,
you know,
it's an escape.
It's a way to help cope with a difficult life.
Um,
that's like,
that's fundamental.
I mean,
you know,
it's so fundamental as you find it in,
in animals.
So I have this clip,
uh,
I have this clip that I show when I give public talks about these researchers
tickling rats.
They actually like put their hand into the cage and kind of rough house these
rats and the rats emit this sort of chirping sound that signals that they're
enjoying this activity.
So these,
um,
and then what happens is,
and this is,
this blows my mind,
is that after they've done this for a little while,
then the researcher will move their hands away and the rats will chase the hand.
So move his hand around the cage and the rats will chase after the hand seeking
out that experience.
So they want to get that stimulation,
they want to get that stimulation again.
And that,
that chasing is no different than the people who are going to go to see your
show tonight or watch your special.
You're just a rat tickling hand as a comic,
you know,
like it's so fundamental to,
to us as organisms define this kind of,
um,
this sort of like ambivalent arousing experience where they're like right on the
edge.
You know,
you're right on the edge of going too far and um,
and you're bonding with other people over it.
It's,
it's really fast by all that about comedy.
But I don't know how exactly it relates to rats.
How do they know that the rats are laughing?
Like when you're tickling a rat had to do,
we really understand what they're feeling means to them.
Um,
so,
so what they do,
they have these bat detectors.
So these are ultra sonic,
so we can't hear him with the human ear.
And what they find they do,
they do.
They do a number of things in these with these experiments.
So one of the things that you can do is you can take that tickling too far.
You make it too aggressive.
And those chirps,
the laughter is replaced by a different vocalization that,
that rats make when they fight.
Oh.
So like,
all right,
all right.
Enough enough.
It's like when it's like if you have kids and they're play fighting and then it
turns,
oh,
or when you're,
like when you were talking about sparring,
sparring is,
is,
it's scary,
but it's also fun.
But then when it turns into a real fight,
it's just get scary.
Right,
right,
right.
And so,
and then they also measure it,
measure these sorts of physiological changes in the rats,
right?
So their brain chemistry and,
and so on.
So there's these,
these guys at Northwestern,
they're trying to create essentially happy pills.
So they're,
they have to understand how do you create positive emotion and rats because they
want to create chemicals that can create positive emotion in rats.
So,
so the goal of understanding this is because they,
like,
most drugs are designed to like,
um,
stop negative emotion.
The,
but the new like,
you know,
the frontiers to create drugs that create positive emotions safely.
You know,
and so,
so they've been for years,
been studying rats and they've been creating and they basically,
I don't know exactly how they do all these studies,
but they,
they essentially find that this physical experience in rats creates a positive
emotional state akin to other pods.
You can,
you know,
you can feed rats and you can do other things to create positive emotional
states.
And they basically find that the brain chemistry following this experience is
the same as the brain chemistry following other positive experiences.
And is unlike the brain chemistry
following negative experiences.
So they're,
they're completely monitoring this animal state.
Exactly.
This is all going on.
So they're pretty aware of what exactly what's going on.
Yeah.
These guys have been doing this stuff for 20 years.
But is it possible that it's just looking for affection and,
uh,
like,
I mean,
how complex is the recognition of this,
this state,
this rat?
It's very simple.
Like,
it's just,
I like this.
Can we be like my cat?
Like when I pet my cat,
she,
you know,
she rubs up against me and she gets excited.
It's not tickling her at all.
Well,
but when you pet the rats,
you don't get the,
you don't get the laughter.
It's really the rough housing that's,
that's president by the way.
I think.
Do with play.
Yeah.
It's total play.
But if it's play,
how do you continue?
I mean,
I wouldn't consider that.
Like I'm tickling.
Yeah.
So,
um,
so the way I think about this is that,
so you have,
um,
uh,
so if you think about about humor from an evolutionary standpoint is that,
um,
you know,
if you,
if you look at nonhuman primates,
the things that that monkeys and apes and bonobos laugh at,
they,
it's,
it's actually called play panting.
So it's physical forms,
physical acts,
so rough and tumble,
play in and tickling and so on.
The situations that,
that induce laughter have this sort of harmless nature to them.
So not all tickling,
for instance,
induces laughter.
You can't tickle yourself.
There's no threat there.
There's no violation.
And if on your way home tonight,
some creepy guy in a trench coat tried to tickle you,
that wouldn't,
that wouldn't be funny either.
Right?
So it's
not,
so the idea is this,
is that you have this sort of sweet spot with tickling.
You have the sweet spot with play fighting.
And,
and then as humans evolved and started to acquire language systems of logic,
um,
cultural norms,
social norms and so on.
Now the world of things that could go wrong started to expand beyond the
physical.
Now it could be a misuse of language.
It could be an absurdity.
It could be farting,
right?
Like cause whether farting is okay or not okay.
It's just a social norm and so the things that could go wrong and the things,
the way those things that could be wrong could also be okay.
Also expanded and it's why I think humor is such a complex thing to study
because there's so many ways to create this positive emotional experiences.
There's only one way or in rats or a few tiny,
a few different ways in rats,
but in humans it could be,
you know,
slap stick.
It could be knock,
knock jokes that have a taboo thing to them.
It could be,
you know what I mean?
There's any number and so it could be a parody,
it could be satire,
but all of them across all these different forms of comedy have the same
element,
this sort of thing that's wrong yet.
Okay.
That's a fascinating way of looking at that.
I don't think most comedians ever sort of conceptualize,
I think we just try to figure out what's funny about something and we don't look
at it what's wrong but okay.
And then how everybody sort of agrees that it's okay.
And that's sort of what,
like this sort of group recognition laughter is.
Yes.
And I think that there's,
I think comedians have been doing this successfully for,
you know,
for a long time.
I what I believe science can provide comedy is it can cut the learning curve.
So imagine you don't need a theory,
but imagine you had a theory.
So imagine you said,
Pete,
I believe you,
I'm going to use the benign violation theory.
Well,
it has certain insights.
So for instance,
um,
one,
one strategy,
we call it the Seinfeld strategy.
So you think about what Jerry Seinfeld does is he takes situations that seem
okay and he points out what's wrong with them,
right?
And,
um,
and when,
when Jerry fails of that,
he,
he rarely offends anyone.
The other strategy is the Silverman strategy.
She takes a situation,
Sarah Silverman takes situation that's wrong and finds a clever way to make it
okay.
You know,
sometimes she puts it to a song and so on and she's,
she's really very nonthreatening and the way that she does this stuff.
So you say,
okay,
so just that insight alone could be useful to a comic,
right?
Like,
okay,
well where am I starting my starting with something that's very clearly wrong to
everybody in the room.
Let me figure out the way I can make it okay.
You know,
a double entendre or misuse of language or find the right victim,
etc. Or am I taking a situation that everybody sees is okay and I have to find a
way to,
to show them how it's also wrong.
Right.
And so that's like,
that's not a bad strategy to start from a writing standpoint versus just like,
oh,
that right.
Like,
you know,
earlier I said,
oh,
that could be a bit,
well,
you know,
and it's like,
okay,
you're just taking this situation.
You see that there's something amiss there and that it could serve as like a a
foundation for a funny joke.
Take very many comedians look at it.
That systematic.
I don't think they do,
but my point is I think that they could write and I think it could help.
Yeah,
I bet you're right.
Makes Sense.
I mean being aware of the mechanisms behind any sort of decision making.
I mean a lot of times that's one of the things that like counseling and therapy
helps the people is to be aware of the mechanisms that lead you to go off the
rails and go on a gambling binge or a drinking binge.
Like recognize the steps are taking place instead of just being caught up in the
wave of momentum and in a constructive side like understanding what is or isn't
funny about something.
It's like almost all writers understand story structure,
but very few people that enjoy a good book do.
Yes.
You know,
they just sort of like enjoy it and go on with it.
But most writers there,
especially when you're writing like something like a novel,
it sort of makes you do that.
You can kind of have to,
it's like the heroes.
If you understand the hero's journey,
then you can write a screenplay,
right?
Yeah.
And,
and,
but people have seen hundreds of heroes journeys,
but they don't,
they don't recognize plot 0.1.
They don't recognize plot 0.2,
even though it happens over and over again.
But what was shocking,
if anything about like the process of creating humor when you're writing your
book?
Um,
surprising.
Maybe a better word.
Yeah.
So,
so one was this idea of,
of how the Palestinians were sort of more Jewish and there are comedy that,
that was very clearly one of them.
So one of the things that stood out to us was,
um,
so we went to the Amazon with patch Adams and a hundred hospital clowns,
patch Adams,
the clown friends,
a movie,
the real patch.
I'm real patch Adams even know he existed.
I thought that was just a construct.
I know he's a real man.
Yeah.
And he's like a big man.
He's like six,
six.
He's,
he's an enormous man.
And so he's not,
he's not Robin.
You think of him looking like Robin Robins,
but it doesn't look at all anything like Robin Williams.
But we wanted to look at whether laughter's the best medicine.
And you know,
the answer to that obviously is no,
you know,
there's other better medicines.
Croaks yes.
But there's good reason to believe that it is useful.
Right.
So,
so,
um,
experiencing positive emotion is,
uh,
experience.
Positive emotion is beneficial in terms of,
of like coping.
That's patch Adams.
The actual patch Adams.
Yep.
Yeah.
He's like,
yeah,
I've seen him wear that chicken on his head.
Exactly.
Anyway,
go ahead.
Oh,
so,
um,
yeah,
don't pull up the pictures of me dressed as a clown.
Please.
It's really bad.
She has made no request in that arena.
Whatever you do,
don't sound like somebody wants pictures of him dressed like a clown.
I was a terrible clown.
Pull them up.
But,
but anyway,
my coauthor was a much better clown then than I am.
And I mean that in a positive way.
Actually.
I'll never say anything bad about a clown ever again.
After spending a hunt,
uh,
like a couple of weeks with a hundred hospital clowns in,
in like this destitute area of,
of the Amazon.
Okay.
So positive emotions help.
Having a good sense of humor is beneficial for coping because we'd like people
who are funny and we like people who can be,
can make jokes in the face of tragedy.
And so it helps muster social support.
So if when the chips are down more than ever,
you need your friends and family.
And if you're,
if you're able to be a little bit light about it all,
it helps those people kind of stick with you versus you just turning into this
horrible,
angry,
sad person who no one wants to be around.
And then the last one,
and I think this is the most important one,
and certainly the one that's most as most understudied is the act of making a
joke about a tragedy.
Not only creates positive emotion leads people to like you,
but it can fundamentally change the way you see that situation.
You can reappraise it in a way that,
um,
that can be beneficial.
So the example I like is when we're in New York,
we met with Todd Hansen who was the head writer at the onion when they publish
their most famous issue two weeks after the nine 11 attacks and what,
what the onion did w which was so brilliant was it instead of doing this sort of
too soon comedy fail and making fun of the victims and making fun of the
tragedy,
they turned it on to the terrorist.
They made fun of the terrorists.
They had like headlines like terrorists surprise to find selves in Hell.
And if you think about it like what if you're laughing at these terrorists,
you've undermined the terror that they're trying to create cause you,
you know,
it's impossible to be scared and amused at the same time.
Right?
So,
so what the onion did was like a great,
it was great for the American people cause it reintroduced comedy into the,
into the culture.
Again,
it brought them some joy and it also made the terrorists a lot less scary.
And so in that way,
like laughter is good medicine because it can serve all these kinds of purposes.
Isn't that why when people are mock to get furious,
because you're sort of,
you're defusing the,
what's,
what's significant about them?
You're mocking it.
Yeah.
You're,
yes.
You're making,
you're making them seem less serious.
Yeah,
absolutely.
That's the classic scene from Goodfellas.
When my a fucking clown,
I'm a clown for you.
Like it's like people get angry if you think something they do is funny,
it becomes a diminishing aspect like you and they almost want to fight you to
get their energy back.
Yeah.
I mean,
well,
so there's a,
so humor,
so we think of comedy as like a very positive thing in the present world,
but it doesn't have its roots actually a rather negative.
So Plato and Aristotle wrote about about humor,
but they saw it as a subversive thing,
so they saw it as a negative kind of thing.
And how so?
Well,
so if you think about it,
what,
um,
uh,
it's sort of like the sneering the laughing at versus the laughing with.
So there's a long history of ridicule,
for instance.
Um,
is that because we were putting down people?
And so in that way you're,
uh,
you know,
and,
and if you think about satire and,
um,
is that,
and this was a time where government was seen as a more positive thing than it
is nowadays.
And so when you,
when you take,
when you're,
when you're using comedy to critique people,
it can be seen as a negative thing.
Right?
And so I'm sorry,
go ahead.
Oh,
so,
so yeah,
so like over and over again,
you sort of find this,
you find this idea of like,
so I'm Thomas Hobbes and Leviathan talked about laughter arising from sudden
glory from,
from the sudden defeat of your enemies.
And you are,
you're laughing as in this sort of superior position.
Hmm.
And,
and I mean,
you can see these things kind of today,
right?
So people telling racist jokes,
people telling sexist jokes,
people going too far with their bill Cosby jokes and making people upset they,
um,
that it's not always used for good,
even if some people are laughing other people or not.
So it can be a really divisive exclusive thing or it could be the kinds of
things that we were talking about earlier where you're bringing everyone
together and celebrating some idea to you know,
together.
That's,
that's fascinating that it used to be thought of as a negative thing.
They used to be thought of like humor was only for mocking purposes.
That wasn't like a community gathering.
One of the things about a standup comic you,
you sort of think of someone standing in front of a group of friends and you
know,
making a speech and everyone laugh and I've always imagined that that was sort
of the,
the origin of it.
Like someone being forced to make a speech somewhere and it's often been
attributed to mark twain.
The Mark Twain did like book readings and he did speeches and he was notoriously
funny in these.
Yes.
And that he was kind of the,
the original standup comedians,
social commentator slash political satirist.
I think he's one of the funniest people ever to this day.
To this day,
he has got lines that could be written by a monitor comedian,
like his line about religion.
Like a religion was,
uh,
was created the first time a con man men,
a sucker or some,
something along those lines.
I'm paraphrasing it when the,
Oh,
it was,
the religion was created the first time a con man mate,
the for the,
for the first con men made the first fool.
So if you,
if you doubt the benign violation theory,
one of the best pieces of evidence for it is a quote that Mark Twain wrote.
He said that the secret source of humor is not joy,
but sorrow.
There is no laughter in heaven.
And like that,
to me,
that line is really profound because,
because what he's essentially saying is you need something wrong.
I'm sorry to repeat myself a lot.
I apologize.
But,
but because heaven's perfect,
because it's blissful.
It's a wonderful place to be,
but there's not jokes,
right.
You know,
because it's because with perfection you,
you do not get comedy.
You need imperfection.
Well,
we're always struggling to try to achieve this ultimate state of bliss.
We're always struggling to try to achieve this state of enlightenment and just
emptiness and being free of all of our negativity.
But what we appreciate and life is the triumphs over the hardships.
What we appreciate is,
you know,
the beer after the long hard day,
you don't want to just wake up and drink a beer.
You're missing the whole fucking point.
You know,
it's like the lottery winner is a classic example.
Someone's just handed some money.
They always wind up losing it and then I'd appreciate it.
It just all falls apart,
slips through their fingers.
Partially because they didn't earn it,
they didn't experience all the difficulty involved in getting to this incredible
state.
We have all these zeros in your bank account.
I think we need adversity.
It's important for us.
Yeah.
I mean well and you're going to have it as humans,
right?
Cause you know,
there's this sort of like the,
the anthropologists of the world talk about how,
um,
social,
like social interactions are about conflict,
right?
Fundamentally about conflict and um,
and you take away the conflict and then you take away that this,
you know,
the sorts of jokes.
Right?
Right.
And so in Twain,
you know,
identified that in a way that has really had a big effect on me because it is
counterintuitive.
Like you're sort of,
you're sort of furrowing your brow over this idea that that humor is this
negative thing like from a historical perspective.
But even,
you know,
even today,
even the conversations we have highlight how it's just a tool and you could use
it for good or you could use it for evil.
You know,
some people could be laughing and others not.
But I think we all agree that the best comedy does one of two things.
It either unites people,
it's very inclusive or it speaks truth to power,
you know,
so you're not putting down,
you're not putting down the PR,
the low status person,
but if you are going to put someone down and you put down the highest
status person,
here's the problem with that,
Sam kinisons bit about feeding starving people in Africa.
So one of the best bits ever,
and it's basically mocking starving people for being stupid enough to live in
the desert.
It's one of the greatest bits of all time.
It's like you're sitting at home trying to enjoy some food you made from scratch
and this guy on TV,
well,
can you help?
Why don't you,
it's like,
why don't you help your right there?
He goes,
what do you do?
What you need to do?
Stop sending the money sound.
People like me sending people that are going to go all the way over there and
go,
hey,
we just drove five hours with your food and it occurred to us they wouldn't be
world hunger,
have you?
People will live with a phone and he goes to this whole crazy bid,
which is so wrong and so fucked up where he's taking starving people come here,
come on mother fucker.
You know what that is,
that sand and it's to be a hundred years from now fucking sand.
We got deserts in America too.
We just don't live it.
I'm as hall and it's so oh wrong,
but so fucking hilarious.
It's one of the best bits ever and it's not punching up and punching up by any
stretch of the imagination,
so I don't buy that.
I think that that's,
that's,
that is the problem with that.
It's like a social justice standpoint and that it's not always applicable.
There's a,
there's a sort of a contract that the audience has the comedian that we know
you're fucking around,
right?
We know Sam Kinison was in Africa and so kids were starving.
He wouldn't be grabbing them and making them eat dirt.
Yes.
Okay.
This is a joke and it's wrong and it's awful,
but it's amazing.
It's amazing because it's wrong and awful.
And the,
the African kids don't need to see it.
Nobody needs to get hurt.
We're just all together in this room and we're going to laugh at it.
So,
um,
I agree with you.
That funny is funny.
And,
and that's you and you know,
my comedian buddies basically say it's not too soon if it's funny.
Right.
You know,
like that's the standard.
So that Joe,
so here's the challenge,
I think of,
of that joke today is because of social media that a joke that wasn't intended
to be broadly consumed,
but of course it was,
it was on HBO,
but,
well,
okay,
so,
so one of his best bits that he did on a young comedian special,
I mean it was a
all right.
Oh,
okay.
I mean,
but so,
so we went to,
we actually went to Scandinavia to,
to,
um,
to look at the Mohammed cartoon controversy.
And that's an example though of now that the world is flat,
that it causes problems because this group of fairly unfunny political cartoons
that were designed to punch down,
we're designed to,
to,
um,
to make Muslims in Denmark feel not welcome,
uh,
and created,
you know,
peaceful demonstrations there and so on.
Somehow made their way to the Middle East and became part of a political,
may basically became a political tool.
And then,
you know,
like literally set,
the Middle East on fire,
like riots,
hundreds of people dead and all that kind of stuff.
I'm cartoons from cartoons.
Well,
these were cartoons of the Prophet Muhammad drawn by,
you know,
Danish people.
Your perspective is the first time I ever heard it put that way,
that part of the issue was the fact that the cartoons weren't good and that they
were punching down.
Yes.
I'm not,
I haven't heard that before.
I,
I don't,
I'm not familiar with the actual cartoons,
but what I've heard was just that they were cartoons and that religious
fundamentalists went fucking crazy and killed,
blow with them.
Well,
yeah,
that's true.
But um,
but that's not you,
that's not the full story.
That's not the full,
so what happened was this sort of right wing newspaper invited cartoonists,
political cartoonist to submit cartoons of the Prophet Mohammed.
Huh.
So there's nothing in the Qur'an that says you can't draw the Prophet Muhammad,
but part of Islamic culture,
it's sort of a no,
no.
Right.
There are some famous depictions of the Muhammad.
There's one in,
in the Supreme Court,
for instance,
that is Supreme Court of the United States.
Really?
Yes.
Do you think that's by design?
I don't know why it's there.
It seems like an anti Islam sentiment.
Like maybe if they knew that that was a no,
no.
And they just said,
you know,
just put it up there to fuck with them.
I have no idea.
I shouldn't do not pull that up.
Okay.
So,
so what they did was they invited these cartoonists to draw these cartoons and
the idea was it was,
it was sort of a,
uh,
kind of like freedom of speech editorial draw Mohamad Day or something like
that.
They got like a dozen people who actually,
you know,
drew these things and some of them were,
were jokes on the newspaper.
So this Guy Lars reffing that we met,
he drew a picture of,
of this kid named Mohammed and he wrote on a chalkboard in Danish,
you know,
this newspapers,
a bunch of like,
you know,
right wing fascists.
Right.
So he,
because he,
they said they would publish anything that they receive.
Another guy,
um,
who,
who drew actually a picture of the prophet with a turban turned bomb.
So it had like the old cannon ball bomb coming out of one kind of thing.
That's the really the one that,
that is like the most upsetting of all of these kinds of things.
What in initially in Denmark,
uh,
there were protests,
so they'll,
5% of the population is Muslim in Denmark.
It's a very small part of the population and it's,
you know,
those folks have their struggles there.
It's,
you know,
it's otherwise a really homogenous place.
They engaged in,
in demonstration,
a peaceful demonstration over all of this.
They weren't happy about it,
kind of liberal folks in,
in Denmark weren't happy about it,
but you know,
it's freedom of speech and you've got to kind of deal with this kind of stuff on
occasion.
And then it sort of went away.
And it wasn't until later someone essentially brought the,
the drawings to the mid,
well actually that's not true.
There was some conversation between countries in the Middle East and the
government and,
and the government stonewalled because we know that we know that this didn't
have to happen because Sweden,
what happen when you say didn't have was that,
um,
so then what ended up happening basically was that folks took these cartoons,
you know,
to Syria and so on.
And the Syrian government use this as a way to get people really fired up.
And then to turn this into is kind of an international,
um,
conflict.
And,
but we know that this was largely political,
um,
because I,
like a year later,
the same kind of thing could have happened in Sweden.
So this artist drew even more inciting cartoons,
whether they were actually drawings of Mohammed's head on the body of a dog.
He do like three panels of this stuff and it,
it showed up in an art gallery.
And that's even more insulting culturally,
you know,
and so,
but what happened very,
very quickly was the Swedish government apologized.
They just basically said,
we don't think this is right.
We're very sorry that this happened.
Um,
they didn't get to a place where they were just like,
oh,
well this is freedom of speech.
He can do whatever he wants.
And that's sort of what happened with the,
with the Danish government at that time.
And so it ended up becoming this like really crazy like political tool.
Um,
you know,
and I ended up getting spread because of the Internet and a lot of people saw
this stuff who would never normally have seen it and,
and so on.
And so in that way,
I mean,
I,
you know,
like whether the cartoonists were being insensitive or not,
it depends.
But what is insensitive?
I mean,
you're,
you're mocking an ideology that's based on animal skins are based on some shit
that was passed on for generation and generation.
If you're talking about Christianity,
you're talking about Scientology.
What I mean when you're mocking things,
if you find something to mock about something and it rings true enough that
people laugh at it,
what is insulting?
He's insulting that they found something ridiculous about your ideology or is
it's insulting that they're bothering to critique your ideology at all or mock
your ideology?
At all and aren't ideologies open targets?
Well,
so I think so according to,
um,
to uh,
political cartoonists.
Absolutely right.
I mean,
I think that's the,
that that's what does it,
who's it not according to who?
Well,
so I think the idea is this,
is that what you can have is some people laughing and some people horrified.
Right.
You know,
and so this is the,
the idea.
I mean,
I mean it really depends on what is your goal.
Like what is your level of sensitivity?
What is your goal?
If your goal is to point out what's wrong with the world and to critique the
world,
then you,
then you're just like,
well,
you know,
if you want to make an Omelet,
you've got to break some eggs,
you know,
and so that's fine.
Um,
but if you do,
if you don't want to put,
if you don't want to punch down,
is that punching down though?
I mean,
is it punching down when you're mocking a controlling ideology that's
responsible for some really regressive ideas?
I mean like the way they treat women,
that women's rights to vote and drive the,
the,
just the wearing of the stoning for adultery,
all the across the board,
things that are a part of Islam.
That's a,
that seems to me at least to be a divisive and damaging sort of ideology.
I don't think it's punching down to mock something.
Well in the,
I think in the case of the Mohammed cartoons,
it was in part because what this newspaper essentially was doing was saying,
if you want to be part of our culture,
you,
you need to be able to laugh about these kinds of things.
And so it was,
it was being used to sort of set these folks apart.
I mean,
you know,
and so,
um,
regardless of what you might think of Islam in,
I think the intentions of the newspaper in that case,
it's hard to see how
that,
it was terribly like righteous.
What,
so I'm confused.
It was just,
that was the most offensive one was Muhammad with his turban was a bomb.
Yes.
That was the most offensive it was.
And in relation to
an ideology that has,
you know,
obviously the most radical aspects of it and not supported by a vast majority of
the Muslim population,
but it has been a large amount of suicide bombings.
It not in Denmark,
not in Denver.
Right across the world with that are associated with Islam,
radical Islam,
jihadists.
Oh yeah.
I mean,
look,
you know,
take any,
um,
take any major religion and you can find a great deal of violence perpetrated in
the name of that,
right.
Religion,
right?
Like it's just,
it just happens to be,
nowadays you're finding it in,
in Islam,
but it,
you've seen it in Catholicism and seen it elsewhere,
right?
I mean,
you know,
so,
uh,
I look,
I'm all for the idea of,
um,
of critiquing,
whether it be religion,
whether it be in government.
I mean,
now we're just getting into my
personal opinions about these things,
but certainly we're getting into thoughts about what is punching up and what is
punching down.
Like Islamophobia is a very strange thing that has like recently joined our
vernacular.
And when you,
you can mock God like the,
the angry man in the clouds,
all you want,
you can mock Jesus.
I mean,
Sam Kinison had hilarious jokes about cheeses.
Like people,
you think Jesus is coming back and here we go.
I think the last thing that Jesus ever said was,
oh,
not my left hand out.
Like he would go,
I think this is the last thing we ever heard from him.
And he did this whole thing about Jesus and Jesus being married and all this
crazy shit.
And nobody,
you know,
I mean he was a Christian for at least started out as a Christian.
Nobody like accused him of Christian of phobia or it wasn't thought of as an
affront to a minority
group.
But that doesn't mean that that Sam's stuff wasn't terribly offensive to
Christian to some Christian,
some Christians.
Sure.
I mean that's essentially what we're,
what we're talking about is like,
so is it,
you know,
it's one thing to make fun of the pope and versus like,
taking something that people hold dear,
but why do they hold it dear there?
There were the whole thing that that comp,
that comedy attacks is what is causing you to believe in this,
what is called,
if I can mock it and I can find holes in it.
And you say that that's offensive.
Well then you're saying the comedies offense.
No,
no,
no.
I want it to be very clear.
So the idea of what I,
what I,
the point that I wanted to make is that in a world in modern day is that a joke
that was very funny and intended for this audience that never would have reached
them 20 years ago.
Now w w w I never reach another audience that finds that joke terribly offensive
and,
you know,
some of it is just like,
okay,
well that just happens.
You know what joke you referring to?
Whatever joke it may be,
like whatever happens in,
in comedy club x shows up on Youtube and people are like,
I can't believe that person was making a rape joke or these kinds of things.
The Mohammed cartoon controversy is an extreme version of that,
that,
um,
these cartoons should have had their,
you know,
15 minutes of fame in Denmark.
They created a bit of conflict,
peaceful protests and so on,
made people feel a little bit,
you know,
set aside,
um,
and that could have passed that,
that now is a much more dangerous thing nowadays because information can,
you can go on Google and pull them up and see these things,
you know,
in that way.
And that,
to me,
that was like a surprising,
fascinating thing about the world of comedy.
Now I know that,
that it's impossible to make a something universally funny because people are
two different.
Um,
and uh,
whether and how you want to go about making your comment.
I'm not going to tell someone how to go about making their comedy or not who
they want to make the victim and who they want to make fun of and all that kind
of stuff.
I mean,
that's,
that's up to the,
to the artist,
right?
But I get confused.
I mean if you're doing standup comedy or are you doing satire and political
satire and cartoons,
if that's the most offensive thing?
I think the issue at all is this cartoon.
I think the issue is the reaction to satire,
the reaction to comedy.
I mean,
people are really burning things in the street and over a guy with a bomb in his
turban.
I think that the true issue is who are these people and why are they freaking
the fuck out over a cartoon?
Yeah.
Well that's a complete total overreaction.
I don't think that's punching down.
Yeah,
I agree with you about this.
No rash.
The,
the fault lies though in the Syrian government in this,
in this particular situation,
because she has stars,
they got ahold of the letting it happen.
I mean this is,
this is a place at the time that,
that,
you know,
everybody was under their thumb,
so they let these riots happened,
right?
They wanted the riots to happen.
You know what I mean?
So that it,
so that chapter in the book reads a little bit like a mystery novel,
right?
Because we're sort of uncovering these clues along the way.
Trying to figure out like how did this bizarre situation actually occur?
Being at a university and you know,
being an academic and being around like really progressive people all the time.
Do you think it necessarily flavor is your idea of what is and isn't acceptable
in terms of comedy?
Cause that that term punching up,
you've used it several times and that's a term that a,
you see all the time when people are criticizing Comedians for,
you know,
a really extreme acts or offensive,
they would consider be offensive jokes even if it's tongue and cheek or what
have you.
Like this concept of punching up is like,
it's fairly fairly,
uh,
current.
Yeah,
I'd say,
um,
I picked that up from the world of comedy,
not
from right when scholars.
Uh,
but I do,
I do.
Yeah.
I certainly,
you know,
Ha I certainly ha like spend time in faculty meetings with,
uh,
my fair share of like super progressive indeed.
Yeah.
I mean,
I'm in a business school so they're not like totally outrageous.
Progressive's but,
but I can see you like,
hey your words and you like tread lightly on,
so you mean you,
you dance the dance of a man with tenure.
Wait,
I've got tenure so I could go even further than I probably a couple of drinks in
you.
You know,
that's really what we need.
I mean I understand,
I get it.
Tension to me should be everything.
And if it's your,
your intention to get violent and upset because someone mocks what you think is
divine,
that's you're a crazy person.
And if they don't make fun of crazy people that are willing to riot and light
things on fire,
regardless of the motivation behind it,
like who started it and who instigated them,
at the end of the day a guy drew a cartoon and you want to kill him.
Like that's the humor.
It's,
and there's no punching down there that that's is like,
if that created that,
that's good.
That's like mocking the ridiculousness of this civilization.
Mocking the ridiculousness of ideology and how attached people become to them
with all,
that's all it is.
A bomb and a hat.
Yeah.
So,
so I'll tell you,
I agree with you in this,
I agree with you in this way.
The I've met the cartoon is he now lives under armed guard God.
And so I like,
I like peed in his panic room.
Like his bathroom has been converted into a panic room.
I'll on all of his walls throughout his house are pictures of,
um,
of him doing this to any religion more or less.
Right.
So,
so for him,
he's,
he's just punching like,
to him it doesn't matter.
He's just like,
I'm there to satirize.
Right.
And so for him,
he's not like,
people might seem as an Islamophobe or whatever it may be,
but he does this with Christians.
He does this with Jews.
He does his holes everywhere.
That's what he does for,
for a living.
Right.
You know,
in that,
in that way.
And so he doesn't think what he did is wrong and he would,
I suspect probably not do it again.
I don't know.
It's a good question.
Again,
crazy.
If you did,
I mean get some guy break into his house with an ax and he had to like hide in
his panic room until the wow,
the equivalent of the FBI came and shot the guy.
It's crazy.
Well there was the guy that got stabbed,
there was a guy in Holland was in it.
The guy who got murdered for some depiction of Mohammed has been more than one
attack.
And that's,
look whenever religion says that if you draw,
our guy will kill you.
Like that is crossing a line.
You know,
and I think there's this,
there's this trend in this society especially,
um,
towards nonviolence and towards recognizing also that the amount of aggression
that it's directed towards Muslims is possibly racist.
And most certainly due to the fact that we have been involved in a prolonged war
with the Middle East.
And I think people are recognizing that there's a lot of the aspects of this war
were unjust and they,
they segment those people off as being marginalized and to be protected with
extreme prejudice as opposed to maybe some Christians who live in Iowa,
which were to be openly mocked you.
Now like no one gets in trouble for mocking Christianity,
but if you mock Islam,
yeah,
I mean how many times has it people living in a Clu?
Islamophobic is a strange thing to say because first of all,
you,
you think of it as a racism thing,
but it's not a race.
It's a religion.
It's an ideology and there's a lot of atheists that live in Pakistan.
There's atheists that live in Syria,
there's atheists that live in Muslim strongholds.
It's an ideology.
It's not,
it has nothing to do with,
with a race.
It's just attached to a race because of a large majority of the people in that
race have this ideology that they subscribed to,
but it's just an operating system and this guy's the only mocking an operating
system.
He's not necessarily mocking everyone.
That has been unfortunate enough to be indoctrinated into some incredibly
controlling and archaic ideology.
Okay.
I'm not,
I do,
you know what I'm saying?
I understand your point.
I really do.
Yeah,
I do.
It's just I the punching down thing,
I was confusing and you're waiting to find him.
Maybe I missed that.
I,
uh,
yeah.
So I mean I do have,
I tend to think about these things in terms of like what are the kind of
behavioral and social effects,
right?
And I,
um,
and again,
I'm not,
I don't think about comedy.
I'm,
I'm thinking about like humor,
like,
you know,
imagine humor in the workplace and in couples and among friends and,
and all these kinds of things.
And I generally do believe that this idea of the best comedy,
whether it be professional or otherwise,
unites people and when it doesn't,
when it divides people,
it's trying to keep an eye out for the week.
It's trying to keep an eye out for the oppressed.
That's my own personal opinion.
Like if it's just a matter of getting laughs,
that's something else.
But if you want to try to take that laughs to the next level,
um,
that's how,
that's the framework that I,
I use in terms of trying to measure a goodness,
so to speak,
but that,
that idea could evolve as I think more about this kind of stuff because some of
it is by virtue of,
I only want to use the start punching up.
You're like,
so if you are a liberal making fun of,
uh,
the new Republican Senate,
you're going to upset conservatives.
Right?
And so I think what you're trying to say is what appears to be punching up or
punching down isn't necessarily the case because there's so many different out
there.
Not only that,
there's a lot of people that fancy themselves as being very sensitive and very
kind,
very open,
but they are absolutely vicious in their attacks on people who don't support
their ideology.
And they will call it punching up.
You will call it punch.
But what you're doing is,
you know,
you have a different point of view on fill in the blank,
gun control,
whatever the fuck it is.
And because they are deemed to be the enemy,
you have a green light to attack them.
Yes.
And in my opinion,
a lot of it is a lack of a psychedelic perspective and that a lot of these
people that form groups,
they formed tribes and they stick within the confines of that tribe.
I mean this,
this,
this is the enemy of religion and psychedelics.
And when you look at ideologies,
especially really super rigid ideologies,
they have to be enforced then the Islamophobia idea,
like the criticizing of Islam being like mocking of a religion that do I do get
it.
I get it.
Well,
you're W so,
um,
I understand what you're saying here is basically saying it's like if you,
that is not to say that you can't,
um,
critique this religion comedically or otherwise because it hurts some people
within it,
uh,
ends up being too narrow minded because you should be able to,
of course,
to critique.
MMM.
Right.
So if you just say,
oh,
well you can't do that because you're hurting,
this group of people will now there,
there is some great benefit of critiquing whatever system of oppression,
system of power that exists.
If you can make someone laugh,
like if you have an opinion,
I have an opinion.
You Go onstage and you state your opinion and I go,
well,
I disagree.
I have a different opinion.
But if you make me laugh with your opinion and I'm almost 40
where we're doing,
right,
right.
But look,
there's a lot of people that have valid opinions that you might not agree with,
but if you are a progressive or your liberal,
it seems that there's an open target to mock them.
Like here's a perfect example is people who don't believe in abortion,
and I'm,
I should preface this,
I'm pro choice 100% always have been.
I think a woman's right to choose is as a very important part of our culture.
The morning after pill,
you know?
But the reality is what is going on?
There's something in your body that could become a life and you choose to stop
that from taking place.
Okay.
Some people have a fundamental problem with that because they think that it's
killing a life.
Right.
And the to,
to pretend that this isn't a debatable issue,
I think is completely disingenuous.
It does become a person eventually.
I'm not saying you shouldn't be able to do it.
I'm saying you absolutely should,
and it's not my fucking business at all.
Okay.
But
people who don't believe in abortion,
it will be marked as being stupid,
as being ignorant,
as being religious anti woman.
You know that they'll fucking,
I'd say the most venomous vile shit about because it doesn't conform with their
very rigid tribal ideology.
That tribe of progressive's.
Yeah,
I agree.
When a tribe of Christians pro pro life,
they would never consider the possibility that it's just a few cells.
Like if I,
if I just give you a pill and those three,
it's three cells.
No,
it's still life.
It's fucking three cells.
It's three cells.
We stopped three cells would,
if it gets to six,
can we stop it at six?
It's a real debate.
Yeah,
I agree with you.
It's a real debate actually.
It's,
uh,
you know,
if you can take a relative relativist perspective,
you can see how very clearly it's a real debate.
Like you can understand why someone would be yes.
Antiabortion yes,
you can.
I mean,
I'm not,
but I can understand.
I see it too,
but to pretend that it,
that it's,
that it's ignorant and to,
to go after it with Vimy vial and,
and the,
and obviously the opposite happens too,
right?
And it's on both sides.
Yeah.
And now were so,
but,
so my question for you is where does this stop?
So let's say,
so,
um,
I,
I wrote a tweet today that said,
uh,
there's a street in la called climate change,
right?
Like,
I just,
you know,
can I saw I pass his ozone street?
I thought that would be a funny tweet.
It clearly didn't work.
Not Great,
but perspective context.
But like,
you're like,
all right,
well,
how much should we be debating climate change at this point?
Right.
You know,
because like in my opinion that's,
it's like the,
it's not overwhelming but it's pretty damn close,
you know?
Um,
and so at some point like,
so in this abortion one,
I think you and I can agree whatever our own personal opinion is,
I can see how another person would have exactly the opposite and have very good
reasons to believe that yes.
At what point does it become a situation where you go,
no,
you're wrong.
Well,
when it comes to the climate change,
but the real issue is what information do you have at your disposal?
Like are you a geologist,
are you a,
do you have a degree?
And understanding the cycles of,
of whether or you just parroting some shit you read on some wacky right wing
website.
I mean,
I don't know if you want to talk to someone about climate change.
There's so many variables when it comes to climate change that are absolutely
incredibly fascinating.
Like the fact that North America at one point in time was under a mile high
sheet of ice and that global cooling,
which has been a part of reality throughout time is much more terrifying than
global warming.
There's all sorts of things.
Everyone's,
the sky is falling,
the sky is falling and I think that human beings are disgusting,
dirty creatures that pollute everywhere we go.
I've seen eight Prius's of keeping track of it.
Eight Prius's in my life,
throw cigarettes out the window.
We're fucking gross were gross and a lot of ways a lot of us are gross.
So there's no debate that we fucked up the atmosphere that my debate is how much
does everybody say,
you know that global warming is here in climate change is caused by people.
How much information do they individually have before they start espousing these
ideas?
And I say very,
yeah.
Oh I agree with that.
I will read,
have you ever read to Chuck Woolery is Twitter,
you remember him from lifting to?
Of course we went back in two and two.
He's a whack job.
He's a crazy super right wing.
Obama hater,
non climate change believer,
listen to,
I read his tweets all the time.
He was going crazy because of the snow
buffalo lake effect stuff.
Evidence that there's no global warming.
I'm like,
no,
actually it's global warming that's contributing to that because there's like
climate change.
So yeah.
I mean I'll tell you this,
one of the things that's been really fun as a scientist is getting to do what
we're doing because scientists are really terrible about getting their ideas out
into the public discourse because they're not rewarded for it.
Right?
So,
so I get rewarded too to write peer reviewed publications that very few people
read,
even fewer people cite and use for future research.
Um,
but because I,
you know,
I wrote this book and I blog and I do all this kind of stuff.
Now I can enter into a conversation with more than just other scientists.
If scientists were,
were much better about getting their ideas out there,
they could actually.
Um,
so cause you know,
politicians are very good about getting their ideas out.
No matter how good or bad the ideas are.
Scientists are really terrible about it.
But they worked very hard to get their ideas right.
You know,
that's their advantage.
Um,
and so you're,
you see this in the sort of climate change you like now they have to rely on
journalists to be the sort of conduit.
They don't do the kind of thing that I'm doing,
which I have really enjoyed doing.
I think this is,
I think humor is such an important thing to understand that you need to do the
peer review publication stuff,
but you also need to enter into a conversation with,
you know,
professionals in the public to talk about this kind of stuff.
Yeah,
figure it out.
Yeah.
I think humor is a weird thing because you could say something and it'd be
really funny and then I can say the exact same thing and no one would laugh or
probably the opposite.
But you know what I'm saying?
It's like everyone has their,
whatever it is about them that makes them funny.
Like in that's very intangible.
There's some weird shit.
Like there's a,
there's some,
some things that would work with some comedians and if you would write them down
on paper,
you would say like Mitch Hedberg.
Again,
I hate to go back to him,
but a lot of this stuff,
if you wrote it down on paper and then read it,
you'd be like,
that's not funny at all.
Don't use that on stage.
But when he does it,
it's genius.
If there is something about personality,
charisma,
all these weird intangible things that are very difficult to measure.
And as a scientist,
how do you account for that when you try to like quantify what,
what is funny or analyze the components?
So it depends on the question.
So,
um,
so if the,
so in some cases that's error,
right?
So in some cases we're not interested in the role that the person plays.
And so what we do is we just randomly assign people to one of two tasks.
And so the,
hopefully you get the same number of,
of Mitch is on the right is on the left,
right?
You know,
one group as in the other group.
And that evens itself out when it comes to understanding the sort of individual
differences he sort of personality differences and so on,
that's a lot harder because you can't randomly assign someone to be like Mitch
or like Joe,
you know,
now you have to measure it and anytime you have to measure some something that
introduces another level of error,
right?
Because how is it that you can measure it accurately,
like reliably.
And so a lack of reliability influences your,
um,
your,
the validity of your conclusions that you can,
um,
that you can draw from.
So I have a particular,
in my own research,
I try to avoid individual differences as much as possible because you're now,
you're not manipulating them.
You're measuring them in anytime you measure versus manipulate it.
It just makes life a whole lot harder.
Where I'm headed though,
I have to pay attention to individual differences because what we're doing in
her role.
So for six years we studied what makes things funny.
The next six years we're going to try to make people funnier.
That's what we're going to be doing.
Funny of me for it.
Yes.
Can you help me?
Sure.
I'm writing a new act.
I just released my old act.
I have to write a new act.
How do I get fun here?
We can,
we can,
that'd be great.
I would love to do that.
Easily.
Mushrooms within limited success.
Uh,
no,
but that's,
I mean,
you know what,
I can't answer that question for sure because no one's ever done that research,
but right.
That's where we're going though.
But to under,
to be able to do that,
we're going to have to measure individual differences cause you're going to have
to figure out how funny if someone is point a and then measure them again at
point B.
And if you're going to have to understand like what did they're good at,
what are they not good at it and so on.
And so,
so the answer,
my quick answer is,
uh,
you got to measure it and it's very hard to do,
but that's where we're headed.
Measuring it and the ability to make someone funny or like,
what would you do?
Would you like analyze their act and say like,
if you did it this way,
or maybe you should approach it that way,
like you would,
would you do it on a like a delivery basis or routine basis?
Bit by bit.
Right.
So,
um,
so you have to have the proper control,
right?
So,
so to me,
I think that the best control,
um,
I have this idea for this project,
I want to do it.
I want to do a TV special on this thing.
You Do,
you take one group of people and you,
you commit them to the kind of typical,
um,
comedy enhancing tools that exist in the world.
Right?
So they,
they do an Improv group,
they do a standup thing,
they read some books about how to do this stuff.
Like you expose
them to funny people,
you know,
who do it for a living and get some coaching.
Right,
right.
That's probably the only things that exist.
If someone really wanted to become funnier,
the only things in exist.
But unlike say carpentry,
there are certain people that just won't be funny.
I,
I struggle to say that because I've seen guys get much better.
Yes.
But there's a certain level of cluelessness that some folks possess that's
inescapable.
So now if the goal is to create funny standup Comedians,
I agree with you.
If the goal is to create someone who is more funny now than they were before
then I say,
well,
maybe you're right.
Because some people are just,
they're just terrible in public and they don't think,
but could I get someone to send funny or emails or be funnier with his kids,
you know,
or to be a better manager to,
so.
So some of it is a matter of identity.
Identifying wears a person's strengths.
What is the medium,
right?
And so,
so when I say improve someone's sense of humor,
it ha,
it can be along many different dimensions.
I don't think the goal is to make funnier standup comics.
I think like we have plenty of funny standup comics and the system works pretty
well.
But when I have like a lot of like really crappy unfunny customer services,
how are things going?
I think that they would have to be super focused on it,
but I think there are.
But I think improving comedy looked even professional chess players and I mean
think about all the incredible disciplines that are,
that are involved,
that need coaching.
Even gymnast when they're at a gold metal level,
they still need constant coaching boxers,
world championship boxer still have coaches.
Bernard Hopkins is 49 years old.
He still has professional coaches that work with them that are constantly
analyzing technique and comics are on their own.
I think what you're doing,
if a comic would uh,
be open minded,
like a lot of comics are very protective of the creative process and the
renegades and like what the fuck do you know when we see your five minutes?
Could do five minutes and then tell me if you could tell jokes for me or correct
my jokes.
Joe,
let's make a show a show what kind of show I can take comics and get them better
use science to make them funny.
Yeah,
I don't know.
It's,
it's,
it would work with some folks,
you know,
open minded folks.
So I'll tell you one of the,
I have an intervention idea,
not for comics,
but for regular everyday people that I believe will help.
And it's uh,
it's facilitating what we call a growth mindset.
So there,
so you can roughly take a person's belief system about their skills and put them
in one of two categories,
either a fixed mindset or a growth mindset.
So this is work by Carol Dweck,
a social psychologist,
a fixed mindset,
believes that you're just sort of born that way.
And so if you have a fixed mindset about intelligence,
for instance,
than an intelligence test is just a race to see how,
how
smart you are,
right?
It's just a ranking system,
And,
and if I rank higher than you,
then I think I'm smarter than you.
And I think that that will always be the case.
But a growth mindset,
a test,
an intelligence test is just a benchmark.
It just tells me how smart I am relative to you right now.
But it shows me where I can go in terms of getting,
getting smarter.
Right?
You can imagine having a fixed or growth mindset about shyness for instance,
like some people believe you're just shy and other people are like,
well,
I'm shy now,
but I can overcome the shyness,
et cetera.
Right?
Humor is,
I think fits.
I think most people have a fixed mindset about their sense of humor.
I think that they just like,
well,
this is how funny I am and this is just,
that's the way it will be.
Right?
But if you can convince them that they can become funnier,
if you can transform them from having a fixed mindset to a growth mindset,
all of a sudden that opens up the possibilities that they'll try to do the
things to actually become funnier.
What variables do you think do you have or you have to address to make someone
funnier?
I have my ideas on this,
but I'm curious as to like what your thoughts are like what variables would you
have to address to try to make someone funding to get more fun?
You have to leave soon.
I do.
Okay.
Don't worry about it.
Five more minutes.
Is that cool?
We're almost done anyway.
All right.
Yeah.
I'm sorry,
I ran out of time at three o'clock.
Oh,
you do?
Yeah.
And it's been three hours.
That's crazy.
Yeah.
Flies by.
I did not,
I did not expect that.
Um,
what,
okay.
What needs to be joining here?
You,
I want to hear what you have to say.
Uh,
self awareness.
One of the big things,
especially with men,
we call that self monitoring in the literature.
Yes.
Men are very clueless about how other people see them because a lot of men go by
there like on a,
uh,
an ego momentum.
Right.
You know,
and especially if they're accomplished in any way,
like if they're a manager and have people that have to listen to them.
It's one of the things that you see happen to people that become famous as well.
It's like when there might have been what happened to,
cause I'm actually write this down.
Yeah.
I'm,
please do.
Um,
self awareness,
especially with men is a real issue.
One of the most annoying things is someone who's a guy who thinks he's funny,
he's not funny at all and tries to like,
you know,
crack jokes and they're just like super obnoxious and you don't see like if you
ever seen a real boarish guy who's not funny at all,
but who is like maybe a manager or somewhere and he tries cracking jokes around
a female employee who might be smarter than him but has to listen to this
fucking idiot because she works for him.
She's like,
Oh God.
Like that is the complete total opposite of funny.
The only way to get that guy to understand how other people would see him.
It's like you would have to point out,
like you'd have to like say you got to look at yourself the way someone else
would see you.
Do you try to actively work on your flaws?
Do you try to actively assess how you're being perceived by others?
Right.
I agree with that.
That's very nice because what it does is it turns someone's attention to their
audience.
Yeah.
Um,
and,
and if you want to be funny,
you can't just think about what you find funny,
you know,
I mean especially like in a mixed setting,
Ken,
but you have to figure out a way to get other people to see your point of view.
So that's nice.
It's like the war though.
D doing standup comedy.
Like one of the tricky aspects of it is like how do you get someone confident
enough to let you take them on a ride?
So yeah,
we do this,
we've been experimenting with this.
Um,
it was just started running this study where we're looking at these,
we use these reflection tasks.
These,
there's like a diary study basically.
So you have someone for like two weeks every day.
At the end of the day do one of two things.
They either talk about what I laughed at and why,
or another one.
So we call that Wila for short.
And then we have Wola what others laughed at and why.
And what we're doing with this study is to see is one better than the other at
getting people to better appreciate humor and better produce humor.
And so what you're suggesting is that Wola what others laughed at and why would
be a more effective intervention then why law?
What I laughed at at why?
Because what a Wola diary study does is it gets you to think about what other
people are finding.
Funny,
not just what you think is funny,
but so it makes you more aware in a sense.
Sort of,
yeah,
but not even what others laugh at,
but how others perceive you because it's a,
it's a,
again,
it's like who's the Messenger is sort of a thing because there are some ideas
that if you gave them to the hands of a skilled comedian,
they could portray those ideas and have it be really hilarious.
Whereas there's other people who would bring up the same joke and they would be
thought off as an a real asshole or short sided or insensitive.
It's a matter of how much do I trust this person's intelligence and how they're
going to tackle a concept.
You know,
if you're talking,
if someone's on stage,
it's like Patton Oswald,
very measured,
intelligent guy.
He's curious and he's going to look at something and go,
why is it that,
and you're going to go,
I want to know what he thinks about this subject.
I'm going to allow him to think for me.
But if it's someone who's like a really crude,
open,
Miker talk,
tackling the same subject,
they might have a good point,
but they enter into it ham handedly.
They don't understand how the audience sees them.
They are too.
Maybe a they too overenthusiastic they look nervous on the mic,
you know,
all there's all these variables or boarish like being an account manager and
have these people have to listen to you.
And you know,
that's uh,
yeah.
So one of the things that I talk about,
like a good starting point is just make fun of yourself.
Just sound like a very simple,
this is,
you know,
um,
the self deprecation,
right?
Because it almost fits the definition of a benign violation.
Like you're pointing out something that's wrong with yourself,
but because it's,
it's you,
you can do it right.
It makes it okay.
And that can lead to,
you know,
like it gets a laugh a lot.
It leads to liking,
you know,
you're not worried about offending people,
at least typically in this way.
And so you can imagine sort of three types of interventions.
So some of them are tactics like that,
you know,
try,
it develops a little bit of self deprecation.
Another one is,
um,
is these sort of like changing the way someone thinks about the world and about
themselves that may lead them to,
um,
to pursue,
uh,
to pursue improvement.
And then this other one,
which I think is just like in general,
it's like you give them
an understanding of the world of humor that they don't under.
They don't get it.
Like most people haven't thought hard about humor the way comics have,
they have,
they don't really think about these individual differences.
They don't think about this punching up,
punching down.
They don't think about,
um,
how it might have its roots in negative emotion.
I mean,
it should be a negative experiences that they don't,
right?
They don't think about the two ways that it can fail,
etc. And so some of it is like you give them a crash course to understand this
topic.
You get them to believe that they can come back and get better at it.
And then you give them a variety of different
strategies and tactics by which to improve it.
And then you force them to practice because it's not going to happen overnight.
It's gonna take a long time.
Again,
the same way that things like meditation and gratitude and so on could be.
So you can,
you can make people more compassionate.
You can make them more like a gracious or have more gratitude.
You can do all these kinds of things,
but none of these interventions happen quickly.
They take weeks and months to,
to do,
it's a practice.
Yeah.
And I think that the growth of any art form,
dependent upon what your starting point is,
is about analyzing the effectiveness of the previous strategies and finding out
what were the holes in the game are.
Yes.
The beautiful thing about comedy is you could watch other people do it well,
and he'd go,
oh,
he's nicer than me.
You know?
Oh,
he smiles.
She smiles.
Oh,
she,
uh,
she just starts off making fun of herself and then makes fun of other people
that are similar to herself.
I see what she's doing,
you know,
when that's,
um,
that's something that it requires you.
Again,
it requires you to analyze yourself.
And if you,
if you're not analyzing yourself,
if you're,
if you're going through life with like,
especially at Eagle blinders,
if you put up ego,
but the worst thing is when a comic bombs and you go,
how you're set go good.
I did really good.
They're really into fuck you did.
I was there stupid.
I saw that you can't,
you're not going to get good if you believe that you did good when you ate shit.
Yeah,
no,
you'll never,
oh yeah.
There's these sort of tongue,
this,
they call it unskilled and unaware ideas.
This is that incompetent people are doubly cursed.
So their curse with their incompetence,
but there they're also a curse with the inability to recognize their
incompetence.
Uh,
and so,
uh,
so you never get better
as a result of it all.
And so those people make lousy comics.
I used to do a bit about dumb people out,
fucking smart people and then explains the pyramids whether around there's
nobody in them.
But one of the part parts of it was about one of the things about being dumb as
a,
you don't realize you're dumb.
Like that's part of being done.
Like there's a lot of like I would say there's a lot of dumb people right now
that are laughing at this joke because they think I'm talking about somebody
else cause you don't realize you're dumb because it's a part of being stupid in
a way to,
I'll send you the paper.
If there's research that they do this,
they do,
what does the term,
again,
we just the skilled and none of were unskilled and unaware that it's like a
double curse.
It is.
Yeah.
That's true.
Like objectivity and introspection.
Yeah.
They're important for anything.
It's sports for writing apps like your friend was talking about like your,
your friend who uh,
wrote the chapter then rewrote it,
not good enough,
rewrote and rewrote it.
The ability to analyze your work.
That's super critical for creating something.
Yeah,
I agree.
But there's also you can overanalyze and you can get to the point where it just
like you fucking hack this diamond down to like a grain of sand.
You're like,
it's not ready.
Yeah.
The question is when do you get to the flat part of the curve?
Most people,
they're not patient enough to get to the flat part of the curve.
[inaudible] right.
That's the,
that's the big issue.
There is also an issue with when do you release a piece of material and put it
like on an album or in a CD or whatever.
Because when you get to a certain point it's perfect,
but sometimes you're on the way there and you record it then and then you do it
afterwards.
You're like,
fuck,
I have all these taglines and now it's better.
Like there's a growth process to performing standup and one of the aspects of
standup that a lot of people find is that there's only one way to get the jokes
better.
You have to do them in front of an audience and they sort of like find their own
life in front of a crowd.
Like when I'm creating new shit,
I will do a bunch of different versions of it and sometimes I just,
uh,
just say,
let me try it backwards.
You know,
maybe we flip it up this way.
Let me add something ridiculous to it.
Let me dig a hole in the beginning and see if I could pull myself out of it.
Right.
Let me take them down at trick road where I,
you know,
I've,
I fake them out and then sneaking in the back door with all this stuff that's
like you,
it only works on stage cause you can only do so much of it in front of a notepad
or a computer.
Yeah,
I agree.
It's a weird art form and that it requires other people's points of view.
Like you could make an awesome song on your own and then go on stage.
I just wrote this last night and just play it going and give you some of that
good,
feel good.
Get in the back of my book.
You know,
you could,
you know what I'm saying?
I recognize that as a callback.
Yes.
Yes it is.
When you're at your very,
it's a weird having a scientist analyze comedy,
you know,
I think,
uh,
this is a fascinating subject man.
I know you're out of time,
but thank you very much.
And it's cool just to,
someone looks at comedy like that cause I think that has really any game be
before you that's done it like that.
Thanks.
Yeah,
it's been great.
The human code people can buy it on amazon.com they can buy.
Is it,
do you have a website?
[inaudible]
dot com humor code.com.
Yeah.
[inaudible] dot org as we discussed,
[inaudible] dot org and this hurl thing,
what are you going to do with this and when can people expect to participate or
these,
uh,
you know,
I get emails sometimes people like,
Oh,
do you need subjects?
I'll be a subject.
Uh,
I dunno,
that's,
that's the tougher ones.
It's stuff takes forever.
It takes years.
Okay,
we'll get it to me.
We'll put it up online,
you know,
we'll tweet it and let everybody know.
That'd be great.
And go buy his book folks.
He knows some shit.
Maybe it could help you.
Young comedians.
Thank you brother.
Appreciate it,
man.
Sure.
Peter Mcgraw,
Ladies and gentlemen.
All right.
Goodbye.